THINK -- STARTING THE MEDIUM --
SINCE I AM SHORT OF VOTES HERE --
WE'RE GONNA START WITH --
READING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS -- WE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER WE HAVE READ THEM -- SO IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO -- JUST
UNDERSTAND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO THE TIMING OF THE
TIMING OF IT.
SO HERE WE GO AND THOSE ARE
ISSUES.
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH.
SEVENTY OKAY HERE WE GO.
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN LET THE NO
ARTS THEATER ARTS EDUCATION
PROGRAM.
A REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
LATINO THEATER COMPANIES
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND OPERATIONS.
OF THE COMPANY OPERATES PLATE
WORK SUMMER YOUTH CONSERVANCY
AND PROVIDES -- SEVENTY FIVE TO
NINETY UNDER SERVED URBAN YOUTH
WITH THE FREE EDUCATION IN
THEATER OPERATIONS. TWENTY EIGHT
A TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
SELF HELP GRAPHIC AN ART A
COMMUNITY ARTS CENTER TO
RENOVATE AND UPGRADE THE
FACILITY.
OF THE SELF HELP GRAPHIC
PROVIDES ARTS EDUCATION ARTIST
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WORKSHOPS AND ART EXHIBITIONS
ANNUALLY [inaudible]
THE DOUBLES.
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA.
YEAH.
IT'S CLOSE ENOUGH LEGAL.
BECAUSE SOME OF THE SERVICE IN
AND OUT -- WE'RE GONNA STOP
RIGHT THERE.
AND GO TO ESTABLISH THE QUORUM.
AND THE TAKE UP THE VOTES
[inaudible]
SO.
CALLED.
KALRA CENTER ALSO YES.
THERE NIELSEN YEAH.
CENTER I'M BURKE.
OKAY FIRST -- I DO WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT FOR ESTABLISHING THE
ON GOING FUNDING FOR THE WORK
FOR WHAT MORE YEARS PROGRAM.
AT THIS GREAT PROGRAM AND I WAS
ONE OF THE EARLY ON
PRESENTATIONS THAT HAD BEEN MADE --
AND THANK THE PUBLICLY THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
FOR THE COLLABORATION AND
IMPROVING OUR STATE CONTRACTING
PRACTICES [inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE GOING TO ADD THE ISSUES
SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY SIX AND
SEVENTY SEVEN TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR.
AND SO NOW WE'RE GONNA DO THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
[inaudible]
NOPE -- FIRST WE'RE GONNA BREAK
THESE UP.
SORRY WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP ISSUES
TO THROUGH [inaudible] FOR NINE
FOURTEEN THROUGH.
TWENTY SIX AND SEVENTY SIX AND
SEVENTY SEVEN THAT'S THE FIRST
VOTE THAT WE WILL BE TAKING SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- NEED A
MOTION A MOVE.
KALRA SENATOR ALSO FINE
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
OKAY NEXT WE'RE TAKING UP ISSUE
THIRTEEN AS A SEPARATE ITEM.
BEEN IN MOTION HERE.
OF NOTE SOME OF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATOR ALSO HI THERE NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
FINALLY WE WILL TAKE UP ISSUES.
ONE FIVE THROUGH. EIGHT FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT TEN THROUGH.
TWELVE AND SEVENTY FOUR WE HAVE
A MOTION.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING NIELSEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- ALTHOUGH
I CENTER NIELSEN NO.
NUMBER.
OKAY.
THE VOTE ALL THE VOTER ONLY
EVERYBODY GOOD ON THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU TO GO BACK TO THE PROPOSALS
[inaudible]
SELECT.
SO OF MEMBERS WE I HAD STARTED
READING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS.
JUST TO READ THEM.
SO I WANT TO GO BACK TO THEM
WHERE WE LEFT OFF.
WE READ ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN ISSUE.
TWENTY EIGHT AND NOW WE'RE ON
ISSUE [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE OKAY.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE KOREAN
AMERICAN NATIONAL MUSEUM.
WHICH IS PROPOSED TO BE BUILT IN
KOREA TOWN IN LOS ANGELES.
THE MUSEUM IS CURRENTLY
FINALIZING THE LEASE AGREEMENT
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
AND THE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP INCLUDES THE
DEVELOPMENT ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OF MULTI USE SPACE.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR A ONE
TIME FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
THE NATIONAL LGBTQ CENTER FOR
THE ARTS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT WILL ALLOW FOR THE RENOVATION
OF THE CENTER AND ALLOW FOR ARTS
FACILITY A PUBLIC SPACE. FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
CITY OF GLENDALE'S TECH
ACCELERATOR PROJECT.
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE CITY
HAS HOSTED AN ANNUAL TECH WEEK
COMPRISED OF DISCUSSIONS PANELS
WORKSHOPS COATING.
AND THEY'RE WORKING OF ANSWERING
COURAGE INNOVATION.
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE USED BY
THE CITY TO ATTRACT QUALIFIED
FIRMS THE CAN SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND OPERATION OF
AN ACCELERATOR.
OF ACCELERATED PROGRAMS WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE COHORT BASED
MENTORSHIP.
AND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS START
UPS LOOKING TO EXPAND.
NEXT A REQUEST FOR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN AFFAIRS. TO FUND ITS
OPERATIONS INCLUDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF STAFF.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO EXECUTE ITS
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITIES.
NEXT ARE A REQUEST FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FUND. FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
RACING THE BACKLOG OF REQUESTS.
THE T. R. F. IS DERIVED FROM
LICENSING FEES PAID BY COURT
REPORTERS AND IS USED TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO TRANSCRIPTS. FOR THE
JUDICATA IN OF ACTIVE LITIGATION.
THE FUND BECAME INSOLVENT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THE RECENT
INCREASE IS EXPECTED TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE FUND IN JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE RECEIVED A
REQUEST FOR TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION.
DOLLARS TO BACK FILL PROPERTY
TAX LOSSES DUE TO THE NORTH BAY
FIRESTONE IN FIRE STORM IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE BUNDY WOULD
PROVIDE BACK FEEL FUNDING FOR
CINEMA COUNTY NAPA COUNTY AND
MENDOCINO COUNTY.
A REQUEST FOR ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE.
ESTABLISHED.
SOME.
LEFT GOES.
LEFT CLOSE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TO
ENCOURAGE THE ORDERLY FORMATION
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THE
PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD INCLUDE
SPECIFIC ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES.
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
A REQUIREMENT TO REPORT ON THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL ON THE
USE OF THE FUNDS [inaudible]
JUST LOOKING [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
YEAH.
OPEN SOURCE OF PAPER BALLOT
VOTING SYSTEMS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
MATCHING FUNDS WERE COUNTIES TO
DEVELOP CERTIFY AND SHARE.
PUBLICLY OWNED OPEN SOURCE PAPER
BALLOT VOTING SYSTEMS.
THE SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
REQUEST WOULD ALLOW THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE TO
ADMINISTER A MATCHING FUND
PROGRAM WITH TWO OR MORE
COUNTIES. TWO THREE THE
DEVELOPMENT CERTIFICATION
GOVERNANCE AND DISTRIBUTION OF
OPEN SOURCE VOTING SYSTEMS.
LICENSE TO ENSURE THEIR FREELY
AVAILABLE TO ANY COUNTY TO USE
AND MODIFY BASED ON THEIR NEEDS.
NEXT IS A REQUEST FOR THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND OUT REACH AND VOTER
EDUCATION EFFORTS WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY VOTERS CHOICE.
ACT COUNTIES.
THE BUSH CHOICE ACT WAS STE THE
CHECK CHARACTER IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND ALLOWED
COUNTIES TO CONDUCT ELECTIONS
UNDER A NEW MODEL THAT PROVIDES
GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND
CONVENIENCE.
INCLUDING EXPANDING.
IN PERSON EARLY VOTING.
ALLOWING VOTERS TO CAST BALLOTS
AND BOTH CENTERS AND MAILING FOR
EVERY.
OF MAILING EVERY VOTER ABOUT.
OF AN ONGOING I REQUEST FOR AN
ONGOING SIX HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR ANNUAL PAYMENT IN LIEU OF
TAXES.
OBLIGATIONS TO COUNTIES.
AS OTHERWISE KNOWN P. I. L. T.
IS A PROCESS TO OFFSET ADVERSE
IMPACTS TO COUNTY PROPERTY TAX
REVENUES.
THE RESULT WHEN THE STATE
REQUIRES PRIVATE PROPERTY FOR
STATE CONTROLLED WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT AREAS.
WE RECEIVD A REQUEST FOR FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
VETERAN CAREER PATHWAYS WORKSHOP
IN THE GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA.
TO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
FOR VETERANS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE PROVIDED
TO THE STATE'S HOMELESS
EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM HEAP. FOR
SUPPORT OF LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO DIRECT
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HOUSING
PLANNING AND PRODUCTION GRANT
INCENTIVE FUNDS. TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
FUND THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS AND HOUSING PROGRAM.
AT AGE CD.
PACIFIC LEE THE FUNDS WOULD
SUPPORT AN INCREASE IN EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. FOR
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM. TO
SUPPORT AT RISK AND HOMELESS
YOUTH.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH WORKS AND
RICHMOND BUILD PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS OFFER TRAINING
ANDEDUCATION TO HELP BOTH YOUTH
AND ADULTS DEVELOPMENT.
EMPLOYMENT READ AND READING THE
SKILLS.
THIS -- WE RECEIVED A REQUEST
FOR EIGHT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE LOS ANGELES
MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST.
THIS FUNDING WILL ASSIST WITH
THE MUSEUM'S EXPANSION INCLUDING%
THE ADDITION OF A PAVILION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR
FIVE YEARS. FOR CAL ALLING TEAR
TO ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA CARE
CORE.
WHICH IS AIMED AT INCENTIVIZING
YOUTH TO WORK AND BE SPITE CARE.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO FUND A
VARIETY OF A VARIETY OF
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS IN THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY. FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR A LANDLORD
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT TO RENT TO
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION PER YEAR FOR TWO
YEARS FOR HOMELESS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE'S
ADVOCACY NONPROFIT.
CAPACITY BUILDING AND REGIONAL
DATA AND COMMUNICATIONS PROJECTS.
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWO YEARS. FOR THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY HOMELESS PLAN.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR AGE THE D.
TO DEVELOP A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
HOMELESS SHELTERS. TO PROVIDE
SHELTER FOOD AND A VARIETY OF
BASIC VETERINARY SERVICES FOR
PETS OF THE HOMELESS CALLED BOTH
ENDS OF THE LEASH.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR THE
CHILD AND DEPENDENT CARE
EXPENSES CREDIT.
REFUNDABLE AND AN ESTIMATED COST
OF EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS.
220-002-2000 TEN THE STATE
CREDIT WAS REFUNDABLE.
WHICH PROVIDED AN INCOME BOOST
BOOST TO LOW INCOME WORKING
HOUSEHOLDS.
NOW THAT THE CREDIT IS NO LONGER
REFUNDABLE.
THE MAJORITY OF THE BENEFIT GOES
TO FAMILIES WITH INCOMES BETWEEN
FIFTY AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IN COMPARISON IN TWENTY TEN WHEN
THE CREDIT WAS REFUNDABLE. 67%
OF THE CREDIT WAS CLAIMED BY
FAMILIES EARNING LESS THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WE RECEIVED A CREDIT A REQUEST
FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ACQUIRE COUNTIES WITH MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. TO ESTABLISH AN
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST THROUGH
INCREASE AND REFORM THE RENTERS
TAX CREDIT.
MORE THAN DOUBLING THE CREDIT.
WHICH CURRENTLY IS SIXTY DOLLARS
FOR SINGLE FILERS AND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS FOR JOINT
OR HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD.
THE PROPOSED ESTIMATED COST OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE RECEIVED A REQUEST
FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
VETERANS MEMORIAL PARK AND
CEMETERY IN THE CITY OF IRVINE.
THE TWO EXISTING STATE VETERANS
CEMETERIES ARE FAR DISTANCES
FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
THEY ARE IN SHASTA COUNTY AND
MONTEREY COUNTY.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE NUMBER OF
MILITARY VETERANS LIVING IN
ORANGE AND LOS ANGELES COUNTIES
WAS OVER.
THREE HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND WE RECEIVED A REQUEST
FOR FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE ORANGE COUNTY HOUSING
FINANCE TRUST.
WHICH IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE EFFORT
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
[inaudible]
ALMOST DONE.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
THAT IT WAS DAMAGED SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS. TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY TO THE LEGAL
MARKET PLACE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN THE MOST HARMED BY
CANNABIS PROHIBITION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
SEVENTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MULTIPLE COMMUNITY
AND PUBLIC SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS.
IN THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY.
THESE INCLUDE THE SANGER
VETERANS PARK THE ROCK WITH POND
PARK IN THE CITY OF SELMA.
AND THE RIDLEY SPORTS PARK.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. TO ALLOW
TEACHERS TO CLAIM A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX DEDUCTION FOR
FEES INCURRED TOWARD THE
COMPLETION OF AND OF AN%
INDUCTION.
APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING THE
CANNABIS LIMITED CHARTER BANKING
AND CREDIT UNION LAW.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. TO DEVELOP A GRANT
PROGRAM TO ASSIST COMMUNITIES
WITH GRAFFITI ABATEMENT AND
BULKY ITEM REMOVAL.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO ASSIST THE
CITY OF RIDLEY.
IN RETAINING AN ARMORY THAT WILL
HELP PROVIDE VETERANS SERVICES
IN THE REGION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CONSTRUCTION
OF A PULL.
SLASH PAD AND MECHANICAL NEEDS
AS PART OF A NEW AQUATIC CENTER
AT THE JACKIE ROBINSON FAMILY
YMCA IN SAN DIEGO.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO UNDO.
A TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN SHIFT
OF PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
FROM COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO CAPITAL IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES BY PROVIDING. ONE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS MADE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL AXES PROGRAM.
AND TWO FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE A TAX CREDIT TO
INCENTIVIZE INVESTMENT IN NON
PREDATORY LOANS.
UNDER BANK TO CALIFORNIANS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO LIMóN.
EIGHT THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FILING FEES CHARGED BY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. TO TAX
EXEMPT ORGANIZATIONS FOR
SUBMITTING AN APPLICATION AND
ANNUAL INFORMATION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO FUND.
PAID FAMILY LEAVE OUT OF REACH.
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING.
BABY BONDING CARE GIVER AND
MILITARY EXIT.
EXIGENCY LEAVE WITH PRIORITY
GIVEN TO COMMUNITIES WITH LOW
PAID FAMILY LEAVE UTILIZATION.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO
APPROPRIATE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO GENERATION GO AT THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THIS IS A COUNTY PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO
APPROPRIATE TO POURED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
THE JUDICIAL RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
AND TO CONSIDER ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS AS ESTIMATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
FUTURE YEARS.
THIS APPROPRIATION WOULD BE
PURSUANT TO SB ONE EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH AUTHORIZES A DEFERRED
RETIREMENT OPTION.
UNDER THE JUDGE'S RETIREMENT
SYSTEM.
J. R. S. TO TO PERMIT A JUDGE TO
LEAVE JUDICIAL OFFICE AND
RECEIVE A RETIREMENT ALLOWANCE
AT A LATER DATE.
UPON REACHING THE PRESCRIBED J.
R. IS TO RETIREMENT AGE.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
JUDGES ARE ABLE. TO BECOME CARE
TAKERS OF BILL RELATIVES OR WHO
OTHERWISE CAN NO LONGER FULFILL
THE JUDICIAL DUTIES.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST TO EXTEND
THE TWO POINT NO FILM AND
TELEVISION TAX CREDIT CARRY
FORWARD PERIOD.
FROM FIVE TO EIGHT YEARS
ALIGNING IT WITH THE CARRY
FORWARD PROVIDED PROVISIONS OF
THE THREE POINT OH CREDIT.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO IMPROVE THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB IN THE CITY OF SANTA PAULA
IN VENTURA COUNTY.
THE BUILDING IS OVER FIFTY YEARS
OLD AND IN NEED OF SIGNIFICANT
UPGRADES AND REPAIRS.
INCLUDING A NEW ROOF SKYLIGHTS
RESTROOM MODELS AND OTHER
INTERIOR IMPROVEMENTS THE CLUB'S
SERVICE BETWEEN SEVENTY AND
NINETY USE EACH DAY.
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR AND ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TO TWO HUNDRED
PER DAY DURING THE SUMMER
[inaudible]
AND FINALLY.
WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO BRING
CALIFORNIA'S HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION
THRESHOLD IN LINE WITH OTHER
STATE [inaudible]
OKAY -- THAT WAS DONE IN LIEU OF
HAVING.
A LOT OF INDIVIDUAL PRESENTATION
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
PATIENCE [inaudible]
OF WE'RE GONNA HOLD OPEN ON ALL
OF THESE POPOSALS AND NOW WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC AND
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON ANY OF
THESE ISSUES -- I GUESS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
YOU IF YOU WOULD IDENTIFY WHICH
OF THE ISSUE THANK YOU -- I'M
ASKING PLEASED TO I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK WITH YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY SO
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER.
SIXTY SEVEN THE CORRECTIVE CRUEL
FLAW IN THE JUDICIAL RETIREMENT
SYSTEM TO GET AFFECTS ALL JUDGES
IN CALIFORNIA.
APPOINTED OR ELECTED SINCE
NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
I PROMISE TO BE BRIEF I KNOW YOU
HAVE A LOT OF ISSUES AND IT'S
DANGEROUS WHEN A JUDGE -- LOWER
PROMISES TO BE BRIEF BUT I WILL
DO MY BEST I AM A JUDGE FROM
THIS PER QUARTER FRESNO COUNTY I
HAVE BEEN FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA JUDGES.
A SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE URGENCY AND THE REASON
WHY IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
INCLUDE THIS IS TRAILER BILL --
THE CRUEL FLYING JERAS TO IS
THAT A JUDGE WHO LEAVES A DAY
BEFORE REACHING THE MANDATORY
RETIREMENT AGE LOSES MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR RETIREMENT -- AS
AN EXAMPLE.
I HAVE FULLY FUNDED MY A SHARE
OF THAT SYSTEM -- THAT SYSTEM IS
ONE HUNDRED AND 2% FUNDED NOW
UNLIKE VERY.
MANY OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
PENSION PROGRAMS.
AND IT HAS BEEN FULLY FUNDED
SINCE ITS INCEPTION.
pESTIMATED BY CALPERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AT TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LIFE OF
THE PLAN THAT IS NOT A ONGOING
BLEEDING.
HOLE IN THE BUDGET THIS IS A
TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE MILLION OVER
THE LIFE OF THE PLAN IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS SMALL CHANGE TOO
GENEROUS.
TO THE PROBLEM WITH CHAIR AS TO
IS THAT IF THE JUDGE DIES OR
LEAVES A DAY BEFORE THEY REACH
THE MANDATORY RETIREMENT AGE
THEY LOSE THEIR DEFINED BENEFIT
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR SPOUSE --
I TRUST YOU ARE IN RECEIPT OF
JUDGE HER OVER -- RATHER.
NOT SENATOR MORE LOCKS A BUDGET
REQUEST AND THE LETTER HOPEFULLY
FROM A PRESIDENT OF THE ALLIANCE
A CALIFORNIA JUDGE STEVE WHITE.
THAT GAVE SOME RATHER HORRIFYING
EXAMPLES OF HOW THIS THING
AFFECT PEOPLE JUDGES LITERALLY
EXTENDING THEIR LIVES ON
CHEMOTHERAPY AND OTHERWISE.
AT TO REACH RETIREMENT AGE SO
THAT THEIR FAMILIES ARE NOT LEFT
WITH LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT THEY
LEARNED.
IT'S A SMALL ASK IT'S IT'S
DESIGNED ONLY TO REACH THOSE
UNIQUE CASES WHERE JUDGES NEED
TO LEAVE.
EITHER BECAUSE THEY'RE BURNED
OUT THERE PHYSICALLY UNABLE TO
CONTINUE THE JOB THEY'RE FACING
A LIFE CRISIS OR FAMILY MEMBERS
FACING.
ONE WITHOUT JUDGES WATCH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS FADE AWAY DUE TO
ALZHEIMER'S HAVING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN GET A BENEFIT FOR
THEM.
NOT KNOWING HOW LONG THEY MIGHT
LIVE UNDER THOSE CONDITIONS
WE'VE HAD JUDGES EXTENDING THEIR
LIVES WITH CHEMOTHERAPY THOSE
EXAMPLES ARE CITED OUR LETTER
AND THERE ARE COUNTLESS OTHERS.
I JUST LEARNED THIS MORNING OF A
JUDGE IN SAN DIEGO SIXTY YEARS
OLD JUST DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER.
I TO FIGURE OUT HOW SHE'S GOING
TO MAKE IT FIVE YEARS TO GET TO
RETIREMENT.
WE ARE ASKING FOR NOTHING MORE
THAN WHAT EVERY OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE IN CALIFORNIA HAS WHICH
IS A RIGHT. TO YEARS OF SERVICE
AT AGE OF RETIREMENT.
IF A JUDGE LEAVES THE JUDGE GETS
NOT A DOLLAR MORE NOT A DAY
SOONER UNDER THIS PROPOSAL.
THE JUDGE WOULD LEAVE WITHOUT A
PAYCHECK WITHOUT A RETIREMENT
CHECK IN IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO
WOULD PAY FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH
BENEFITS WHILE THEY AWAIT THE
CHECK THAT ULTIMATELY COMES TO
THEM OR THEIR SURVIVORS.
AT THE NORMAL RETIREMENT DATE.
THE VERY SMALL REQUEST WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CAREFULLY CONSIDER PUTTING IT
INTO THAT BUDGET SO WE CAN GET
THIS DONE BEFORE ANOTHER JUDGE
FACES THAT COOLS THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THANK YOU THANK YOU
EVERY SERVICE -- CONSIDERING THE
NUMBER OF OF VISITORS WE HAVE
YOUR IF WE COULD LEAVEIT TO A
MAX OF TWO MINUTES OUT REALLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY THREE THE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS GOING INTO
A ORANGE COUNTY HOUSING FINANCE
FRONT.
THE TRUST WAS ESTABLISHED LAST
YEAR IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE
COUNTY AND CITIES WITH AN ORANGE
COUNTY TO COLLABORATIVELY
ADDRESS THEIR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION -- THIS FIRST BIT OF
PEP FUNDING WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
IMMEDIATELY START UILDING
SUPPORT OF HOUSING UNITS WHICH
ARE ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE
THANK YOU.
SPARKY HARLAN CEO BILL WILSON
CENTER IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SPEAKING TO ITEM FORTY THREE THE
HOMELESS YOUTH HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING.
I SPEAK TO THIS BECAUSE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY CURRENTLY PROVIDES
LESS THAN 5% OF ITS FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH.
AND CONSIDERS IT A LOW PRIORITY
EVEN THOUGH THE LAST POINT IN
TIME COUNT.
HOMELESS YOUTH REPRESENTED 40%
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION.
INDICATIONS ARE IT'S GOING TO GO
UP 50% IN THIS CURRENT POINT IN
TIME COUNT.
BEING CLOSE TO FOUR THOUSAND WE
NEED TO HAVE A PRIORITY
STATEWIDE ON HOMELESS YOUTH
BECAUSE FRANKLY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS JUST DO NOT DO
THAT FOR THE HEAT MONEY.
EVEN THOUGH THE COUNTY BROADBAND
ELEVEN MILLION BASED ON OUR
pACCOUNT FOR YOU.
THEY GAVE A MILLION TO YOU IF WE
HAD GOTTEN THAT TOTAL PERCENTAGE
SO WHEN YOU CONSIDER HEAT MONEY
IF YOU SAY A MINIMUM FOR YOU OR
BASED ON YOUR POINT IN TIME
COUNT.
THAT WOULD BE A HUGE BENEFIT TO
US TO GET MORE MONEY FOR
HOMELESS YOU CURRENTLY MOST OF
OUR MONEY FOR HOMELESS YOUTH
EITHER COMES FROM CALLOW YES.
OR FEDERAL HUD BUT NOT LOCAL
JURISDICTION SO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU.
CHAIR NICHOLAS HAD ON WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIFTY
RELATING TO COUNTY INDEPENDENT
REDUCING COMMISSIONS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE STATE IN
CONGRESSIONAL REDUCING
CALIFORNIA IS CONSIDERED THE
GOLD STANDARD FOR REDISTRICTING
REFORM?
TERMS HAVING ELIMINATED PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING BRIEFLY
DISCRIMINATORY GERRYMANDERING
LOTS OF IN SINCE THE PRONE COME
TO BIAS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
GERRYMANDERING CONTINUES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SB?
ONE THIRTY NINE FOR PARK
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH THE SAMEINDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS THAT
WORKS SO WELL AT THE STATE LEVEL
FROM THE LEGISLATURE IS ALREADY
DONE FOR LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES. TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S NO COST BURDEN ON SMALL
TO MID SIZE COUNTIES HOWEVER IT
DOES COME SB ONE THIRTY NINE
DOES IS CONDITION ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
A AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THIS
REQUEST COMING IN TO ENSURE THAT.
THIS BILL IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
INSERT ALL COUNTIES CAN UP
INDEPENDENT COMMISSIONS LEADING
TO FAIR LINES WHICH WILL LAST
FOR THE NEXT DECADE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK MY NAME STORE ROSA WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPEAKING ON ITEM.
FIFTY PLEASE SB.
ONE THIRTY NINE LEE HELPED LEAD
THE FIGHT FOR INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING AT THE STATE LEVEL
IN OUR LOCAL LEAGUES.
OF HELPED LEAD THE FIGHT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHEN THERE ARE THE FEW
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION THAT DO EXIST.
THEY WORK TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
REALLY STRONG ROBUST PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND THAT THE
COMMISSIONERS THAT ARE -- CHOSEN
REALLY REPRESENT THE DIVERSITY
OF THE CAN COMMUNITY AND THAT IS
A KEY PROBLEM BECAUSE WE ARE A
MAJORITY MINORITY STATE BUT THAT
WONDERFUL DIVERSITY IS NOT
REFLECTED IN OUR LOCAL OFFICES
IN PARTICULAR COUNTY SUPERVISORS
SEATS SO.
IN ORDER TO HAVE A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY WE
THINK IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS BILL BE FUNDED THANK
YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND
HARDWORKING BUDGET STAFF I'M
EVAN MEN CAN WITH CALIFORNIA
VOICES FOR PROGRESS AND I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON ISSUE.
FIFTY AT THE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
AND IF PEOPLE HAVE MORE FAITH IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WHEN IT'S
INDEPENDENT BODIES NOT THE
INCUMBENTS RUNNING FOR ELECTION
DRAWING THE DISTRICT LINES.
AS REDISTRICTING ONLY HAPPENS
ONCE EVERY TEN YEARS AFTER THE
FEDERAL CENSUS AND THEN WE'RE
STUCK WITH THOSE DISTRICTS FOR
THE NEXT TEN YEARS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DISTRICTS
ARE GERRYMANDERED AGAIN.
SO AND THAT MAKES THIS BILL AND
THIS BUDGET REQUEST OF CRITICAL
ASTON'S AND CRITICAL TIME IN A
CRITICAL EYE TIME SENSITIVE
MANNER.
AND SO WE'RE REALLY HOPING THAT
THIS -- CAN BE INCLUDED IN THE
SENATE BUDGET PROPOSAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
A LUIS MERON TâM BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA BE -- HERE THIS
MORNING TO SUPPORT. FORTY FORTY
ONE FORTY TWO AND FIFTY TWO ALL
IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS OR FOR
PARTIAL SOLUTIONS TO
CALIFORNIA'S.
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS VERY
PLEASED TODAY TO BE ABLE ALSO TO
RELAY SUPPORT FROM OUR REGIONAL
AFFILIATES -- EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE AND SOUTH BAY IN BE IN
PARTICULAR SUPPORT -- FOR FORTY
TWO THAT'S GOING TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED A SUCH ASSISTANCE TO
RENTERS WHO FACE THE THREAT OF
EVICTION -- CHAIRS YOU KNOW THIS
IS A HUGE ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY -- AND A MUCH NEEDED
BUDGET REQUEST THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS CAL
ASCO.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE THE GRANT FUNDING FOR LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS
THAT WOULD ALLOW.
SMALLER LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSIONS TO ADDRESS --
CONCERNS ABOUT.
A SERVICES PROVIDED IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THESE
GRAND PLANS AGAIN A SMALL --
INVESTMENT OF STATE RESOURCES
BUT REALLY COULD CREATE SOME
SIGNIFICANT EFFICIENCIES -- AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN TERMS OF
SERVICE PROVISION AND TAXPAYER
SAVINGS.
I ALSO WANTED TO REPRESENT THE
SUPPORT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
AND THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR SENATOR STAFF --
MY NAME IS TOM PAULINO I AM
THIRTY YEARS OLD THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO GAY MEN'S
CHORUS AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE THIRTY AFTER THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR LGBTQ ARTS --
WHEN I WAS IN FIRST GRADE MY
FIRST -- EXPOSURE TO THE ARTS
WAS TO AUDITION FOR THE ROLE OF
THE WICKED WITCH OF THE WEST IN
THE WIZARD OF OZ.
AND MY TEACHER RAN THAT BY MY
MOTHER -- TO SAY THAT WAS OKAY
AND MY MOM SAID ABSOLUTELY --
FROM THEN I WENT ON TO
PARTICIPATING CHORUS -- IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE -- IT'S BEEN
A GREAT ASSET TO MY LIFE AND WHO
I AM -- DECADES BEFORE THAT
OCTOBER THIRTIETH NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED GAY MEN IN
SAN FRANCISCO GATHERED IN A
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND EMERGED FROM
THAT SCHOOL AS THE FIRST COURSE
IN THE WORLD TO USE THE WORD GAY
AND THEIR NAME.
AND FROM THAT POINT THERE ARE
NOW HUNDREDS OF GATE LGBTQ
COURSES AROUND THE WORLD ON ALL
CONTINENTS EXCEPT ANTARCTICA.
AND THE LGBTQ CENTER OF THE ARTS
IS OUR HOME IS THE SAN FRANCISCO
GAY MEN'S CHORUS IS HOME BUT IT
IS ALSO THE HOME TO EVERY LGBT
Q..
YOUNG CHILD IN FIRST GRADE
AUDITIONING FOR A ROLETHAT
THEIR TEACHER MASS THEIR PARENT
IF IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THEM TO
BE AND AT HOME AND AROUND THE
WORLD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
MADAM CHAIR OF DAVID JONES HERE
ON BEHALF OF THREE ITEMS -- ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE ON BEHALF CITY
GLENDALE THE TECH GRANT WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT OF THEM -- ITEM
NUMBER FORTY ONE ABOUT HALF THE
CITIES OF PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA BURBANK GLENDALE IN THE
CITIES OF MARIN OF THIS FORMAL
HOUSING PROPOSAL I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT.
AND LASTLY ABOUT THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA THAT SUFFERED A
CATASTROPHIC LOSS OF FIRE A
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR TAKE TO HAVE
CONTINUED PROPERTY TAX RELIEF
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES ARE STILL
SUFFERING FROM THEIR TRAGIC
LOSSES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM TURN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON THE OF THE
COUNTIES OF CINEMA NAPA AND
MENDOCINO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL WE
UNDERSTAND THE UNPRECEDENTED
NATURE.
OF ASKING FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
OF BACK FILL -- THE COUNTY HAS
BEEN IN REGULAR CORRESPONDENCE
WITH THE STATE.
THE NUMBER OF HOMES THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN REBUILT SINCE THE FIRES IS
NOT EVEN 10%.
OF COURSE THE PROPERTY TAXES
THAT ARE FLOWING TO THECOUNTY
GENERAL FUND ARE NOT MEETING THE
BUDGETARY NEEDS OF THE COUNTY
AND ALSO AFFECTS THE SCHOOLS.
SO I GIVEN THE NEW NORMAL THAT
FOLKS TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME
WE'RE HOPING THAT EXTENDED
ASSISTANCE FOR COUNTIES AT THAT
LEVEL OF DEVASTATION COULD BE
TREATED AS ALSO PART OF THE NEW
NORMAL.
I SO WE ARE JUROR APPROVAL OF
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING WHEN
OTHER COMMITTEE BEGINS TO CLOSE
HIS EYES OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CONSIDERATION.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WAS A RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AS THE HELD
BACK FILL -- WE SUPPORT THIS
REQUEST TO MAKE PERMANENT THE
BILL TO THE STATE'S OBLIGATION
TO PAY POLL TO COUNTIES -- THIS
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
FORTY NINE IS WAY TO BACK FILL
COUNTY REVENUES OF ASSOCIATED
WITH THE LOSS OF TAXES FROM THE
STATE ACQUISITION OF PRIVATE
LANDS -- THIS MANDATORY SHALL
WAS CHANGED TO A MAIN TWENTY
FIFTEEN ALL THIS REQUEST DOES IS
RESTORE THAT OBLIGATION IT'S A
MODEST REQUESTED SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
YEAR.
BUT IT GOES A LONG WAY TO
HELPING SMALL RURAL COUNTIES
PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX CAPRI ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR OF THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PAID FAMILY
LEAVE OUR EACH THANK YOU.
BUT AFTER CHAIR -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND G. ON THE
CITY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ALAMEDA I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
THE CITY SUPPORT OF ISSUE. FIFTY
ONE TO INCREASE AND REFORM THEIR
INTEREST TAX CREDIT IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO DO EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
HELP IMPLEMENT THE CANNABIS
LIMITED CHARTER BANKING LAW
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEDICINE BY ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
TWO THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS HOUSING PROGRAM THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE WHO COULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
FIFTY SIX IT'S A TEACHER
INDUCTION TAX DEDUCTION AND IT
PROVIDES A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR TAX DEDUCTION -- TO
TEACHERS WHO HAVE TO PAY FOR
THEIR INDUCTION PROGRAM --
PROVIDES TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ABOVE THE LINE TAX
DEDUCTION FOR THREE YEARS --
ONLY COSTS THE STATE AND IN
TERMS OF REVENUE LOSS TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR FIVE YEARS AND WE WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LOS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE NUMBER FORTY THREE
AROUND HOMELESS YOUTH AND
CREATING AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE -- SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
TO SUPPORT YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT STATE PROVIDES ON
AN ONGOING BASIS.
IS LESS THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN NO SURPRISE
TO ME THAT WE HAVE SUCH AN
ONGOING CRISIS AND ARE EXPLODING
HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND WITH THEM BASED ON THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN POINT TIME
COUNTS CALIFORNIA HAD 54% OF THE
NATION'S YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND IF WE CAN
ADDRESS AND WORK WITH THEM WHILE
THEY'RE YOUNG AND SUPPORT THEIR
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS WE CAN
REALLY GO A LONG WAY TO SUPPORT
THEM TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT.
IN THE LONG RUN AND IF WE DON'T
DO ANYTHING ON AN ONGOING BASIS
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM AROUND THE GROWING
HOMELESS POPULATION THE STATE.
AND HOPE YOU CONSIDER DOING
SOMETHING ON AN ONGOING BASIS
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SHERILYN ADAMS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF OUR
CONCERT YOU SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BOARD CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
USED HERE TO SPEAK ON ISSUE.
FORTY THREE AS KEN MENTIONED
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF OUR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION IN THE STATE AND HAVE
LARGELY HAD THEIR NEEDS GO.
UNMET FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO HOUSING AND SHELTER EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT AND ALL THE
SPORTS THAT SUPPORTS THEY NEED
TO SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD. 50% OF ALL FOLKS IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHO WERE HOMELESS
BECAME ALMOST BEFORE THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE IF WE CAN ADDRESS
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WE GO A LONG
WAY TOWARDS PREVENTING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
AND ALLEVIATING THE PAIN THAT
FOLKS EXPERIENCE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
BELCHER [inaudible]
SERRA BURKE.
A HOST OF ME WITH A CALPERS
ACCOUNTS LATER IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM.
FORTY ONE MODEST REQUEST FOR A
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED.
HOUSING PLANNING A PRODUCTION
GRANTS AS WE HONOR SIR IS A
MASSIVE NEED WE NEED IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE'RE GOING THROUGH.
THE SPECTER.
UP APPROVAL OF THIS REQUEST.
GOOD AFTERNOON SASHA HER NAME
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM FORTY TO THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
AND HOUSING PROGRAM.
WE'VE SEEN STRUGGLING RENTERS --
HARDWORKING RENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE PUSHED INTO THE STREETS BY
HIGH HOUSING COSTS AND IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THEY BE PROVIDED --
RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDE
STABILITY AND ALSO LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE THERE NOT
IMPROPERLY AFFECTED SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS ITEM THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TIFFANY OPTION SKI AND I AM THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO
GAY MEN'S CHORUS.
AS WELL AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY AND SOCIAL IMPACT
ADDS AND ASK AND WE ARE  TECH
COMPANY WITH OUR HEADQUARTERS.
IN THE TENDERLOIN IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
I FIRST I'M HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE THIRTY I FIRST
BECAME INVOLVED WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO GAY MEN'S CHORUS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
ORGANIZATION HAD ANNOUNCED PLANS
FOR ITS LAVENDER PEN TO WERE
A JOURNEY THROUGH FIVE STATE
SITUATED IN THE DEEP SOUTH ALL
OF WHICH HAVE PASSED ANTI LGBT
Q. LEGISLATION IN ONE FORM OR
THE OTHER.
THIS TOUR SOUGHT NEITHER TO
PREACH ITS MISSION TO THE
COMMUNITIES THEY VISITED NOR
DISMISSED THE VALUES THESE
COMMUNITIES OF HELD.
INSTEAD IT SOUGHT TO BRING
RESOURCES TO THE SMALL OFTEN
INVISIBLE AND VERY UNDER
RESOURCE LGBT COMMUNITY AND
NONPROFITS SERVING VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
IT'S NOT TO USE MUSIC AS AN
EQUALIZER AND VEHICLE FOR
ENGAGING IN DEEPLY LAYERED
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT INCLUSIVITY
ACCEPTANCE AND CIVIL LIBERTIES
FOR ALL.
AND IT DID SO BY LEVERAGING THE
BEAUTY OF MUSIC TO DO IT IT
CHANGES SO MANY HEARTS AND MINDS.
AND IT HURTS MY EYES WERE OPENED
IN WAYS THEY HADN'T BEEN OPENED
BEFORE I'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING LIKE IT IN MY LIFE.
AS A MOTHER OF A SIX YEAR OLD
WHO'S ONLY WORLD RIGHT NOW IS
WHERE THE BERRY OF ENTRY TO
ACCEPTANCE IS NOT BEING NICE --
I FEAR THE DAY WHEN SHE'S
REMOVED FROM THAT WORLD WHERE
DISCRIMINATION HASN'T YET
ENTERED.
HER MIND I KNOW IT'S I KNOW IT'S
COMING BUT FOR NOW I'D LOVE TO
PRESERVE THAT NOT ONLY FOR HER
BUT FOR SO MANY POPULATIONS THAT
NEEDED. TO THE SAN FRANCISCO GAY
MEN'S CHORUS IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME AND MY FAMILY.
BUT IT'S ALSO BECOME A CENTRAL
ORGANIZATION FOR ZENDESK -- OUR
HEADQUARTERS AS I MENTIONED ARE
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND WE'VE SEEN
THE CHORUS AS A CENTRAL DRIVING
FORCE FOR US WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INCLUSIVITY ESPECIALLY AROUND
THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
AND WE SEE THE CHORUS AS SUCH A
POWERFUL ARTS ORGANIZATION TO
GALVANIZE COMMUNITIES AROUND
CHANGE.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW HERE LGBT Q.
ACCEPTED SAID INCLUDES
INCLUSIVITY CONTINUES TO BE A
BATTLE.
YOU CAN EVEN ARISE TO THE LEVER
LEVEL OF SECURING PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDACY AND CAN STILL BE
PUBLICLY HARASSED AND HIT WITH
HATEFUL SPEECH.
SLURS AND DISRESPECT.
TEEN SUICIDE AMONG THE LGBTQ
POPULATION IS HIGHER THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
SO IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE
RESOURCES ARE SCARCE AND EVEN
NON EXISTENT.
THAT'S WHY THE SAN FRANCISCO GAY
MEN'S CHORUS HAS PURCHASED A
PERMANENT HOME FOR ITSELF AT ONE
SEVENTY VALENCIA STREET IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
BUT THIS HOME IS NOT JUST A HOME
FOR THE CHORUS IT IS TO BE THE
NATION'S VERY FIRST NATIONAL
LGBTQ CENTER FOR THE ARTS FOR
ARTISTS FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND EVEN THE UNITED STATES.
THE CENTER CAN GO WANT TO CREATE
A NEW GENERATION OF WORKS THAT
WILL ELEVATE THE CONVERSATION ON
INCLUSIVITY IT WILL SERVE AS A
BEACON OF HOPE AND INNOVATION.
IT WILL BE A SPACE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN MAKE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY RELEVANT NEW WORKS
THAT WILL NOT ONLY GIVE VOICE TO
TODAY'S LGBT COMMUNITY WILL SEEK
TO CULTIVATE A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AUDIENCE AS WELL.
THE STATE SUPPORT IS CRITICAL TO
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS MEETING
PROJECT I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN HELPING FUND THIS
GROUNDBREAKING PROJECT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DALE
MARSDEN SUPERINTENDENT SAN
MARINO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HERE TO SPEAK ON
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SIX
GENERATION GO THIS IS A YOUTH
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
HOPING TO TAKE TO SCALE -- WHEN
I START WITH A DISTRICTS --
SEVEN YEARS AGO OUR GRADUATION
REGION -- SIMPLICITY -- ONE THE
HIGHEST POVERTY DISTRICTS IN THE
IN THE NATION -- WE ARE -- TENTH
LARGEST DISTRICT IN STATE OUR
GRADUATION RATE WAS SIXTY SIX
POINT 8% WHEN WE STARTED SEVEN
YEARS AGO TODAY OR NINETY ONE
POINT 8% PASSING STATE NATIONAL
COUNTY AVERAGE WITH A HIGH
POVERTY COMMUTE ABOUT 90% 92%.
TRADITIONALLY MARGINALIZED
STUDENTS OFTEN SEEN AS A
FORGOTTEN CITY WE'VE DEVELOPED
THE ROBUST INTERNSHIP PROGRAM
WITH THE COUNTY SALMON TO DO YOU
KNOW.
THE GOAL WITH THE PILOT INSANITY
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
LARGEST DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY
IS THE BILL THE SOUTH ALL THIRTY
THREE DISTRICTS WOULD MAKE IT
WITHIN THE COUNTY BELIEVE.
GENERATION GO AS A MODEL FOR THE
STATE AND NATION IN YOUTHAND A
NEW APPROACH THAT WE WOULD CALL
A A CAREER TO COLLEGE YEAR A LOT
ABOUT COLLEGE TO CAREER THIS IS
CREATE A COLLEGE WITH THE
GAUGING THE WORK FORCE. TO TO
PLAY WITH US IN THE SPACE OF
INSURING STUDENTS HAVE A ROBUST
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN INTERNSHIP
IT'S A PAID INTERNSHIP FOR
HUNDRED TWENTY HOURS.
ALLOW STUDENTS TO CONNECTED TO A
JOB A LIKE A INDUSTRYSECTOR
FROM ONE OF OUR FIFTY HIGH
GROWTH HIGH DEMAND HIGH WAGE
SECTORS IN OUR PATHWAYS IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO WE'RE HERE TO
ASK YOUR SUPPORT. FOR THAT ITEM
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT A YOUR
SUPPORT WILL HELP DISPUTE
CATALYST TO TAKE US FOR THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN TWENTY SEVEN
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE ENGAGED. TO
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WE'RE VERY
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN -- TAKE THAT
THIS VERY CRITICAL PART POINT
THERE WERE AT IT'S A IT'S A
TIPPING POINT FOR US IN YOUR
SUPPORT WILL HELP US TAKE IT TO
THE NEXT LEVEL.
IT'LL IMPACT THIS ENTIRE STATE
WE BELIEVE IS IT'S WHAT THE
STATE HAS BEEN AFTER FOR SOME
TIME WE'RE DOING IT SEVENTY OF
CITY THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS DIANA RODRIGUEZ ON
THE PRESIDENT OF SAN BERNARDINO
VALLEY COLLEGE IN SPEAKING TO
ISSUE SIXTY SIX IS WHILE.
I GIVE HER DOCTOR MARS DâN GIVE
THE STATISTICS OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND OF THE NEED WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
SO I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU. TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO IMAGINE A CALIFORNIA.
WHERE EVERY STUDENT GRADUATES
WITH COLLEGE CREDIT?
ROGER WAIT HIGH SCHOOL WITH WORK
EXPERIENCE AND GRADUATES HIGH
SCHOOL WITH A WELL ROUNDED
EDUCATION READY TO WORK.
IMAGINE THAT.
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT SOMEBODY
DECEMBER DINO COUNTY WERE
ALREADY WORKING TO ACHIEVE THAT
REALITY.
SO HOW ARE WE DOING THAT.
SOMEBODY IN A VALLEY COLLEGE.
IS WORKING SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THE COUNTY
ASSEMBLY DINO UNIFIED.
IN A IN THE INITIATIVE
GENERATION GO TOGETHER WE
PILOTED THIS PROGRAM WITH THIRTY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THE FIRST COMPLETED COLLEGE
COURSES AT SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
COLLEGE.
IN COMPLETED A WORKFORCE
READINESS CERTIFICATE.
THEN THEY RECEIVE HANDS ON WORK
EXPERIENCE IN A PAID INTERNSHIP.
AT ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER IN MANY LARGE. FIVE FIVE
OTHER LARGE EMPLOYERS THROUGHOUT
OUR CITY.
THE RESULTS OF OUR PILOT WERE
PHENOMENAL.
DALY SCHOOL ATTENDANCE WAS UP
HIGHER THAN USUAL.
WE HAD A 100% GRADUATION RATE
WITH THE STUDENTS.
MORE THAN HALF COMPLETED COLLEGE
PREP COURSES TO GO TO UC AND CAL
STATE.
AND SOME OF THEM EVEN EVEN
SECURED EMPLOYMENT WITH THE HOST
OF THEIR INTERNSHIP.
SIMPLY PUT.
OUR CRADLE TO CAREER INITIATIVE
IS TRULY WORKING AND CAN BE A
MODEL FOR THE STATE.
WE'VE GROWN OUR PILOT FROM
THIRTY STUDENTS. TWO THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND WE WANT TO TAKE THAT EVEN
FURTHER.
OUR VISION IS TO IMPLEMENT.
GENERATION GOES DOCTOR MARSDEN
SAID ACROSS ALL THIRTY THREE
DISTRICTS ACROSS OUR COUNTY.
IN TOUCH EVERY JUNIOR AND SENIOR
STUDENT WITHIN THOSE HIGH
SCHOOLS.
IMAGINE THE IMPACT THAT THAT
COULD HAVE A LOWERING
CALIFORNIA'S POVERTY RATES AND
BOOSTING OUR PROSPERITY.
THAT'S WHY ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS TODAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE INVESTMENT OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS DEGENERATION GO
I THINK OUR STUDENTS DESERVE IT.
I THINK OUR COMMUNITIES DESERVE
IT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR FILL CONTRA NINE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE CAN A SIMILAR
DEAL COUNTY WORKFORCE BOARD I AM
THE PRESIDENT OF OUR CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF ITEM NUMBER --
SIXTY SIX I'M THE THIRD LEG OF
THAT STOOL OF WHERE WE'VE COME
TOGETHER WITH OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM WITH DALE MARCIN AND ARE
OF JUNIOR COLLEGE SYSTEM.
AS THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY A STEP
FORWARD YOU KNOW AS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE STARTS TO
SHRINK AND THAT WE FIND
EMPLOYERS HIGH I MEAN EMPLOYEES
HARDER AND HARDER TO FIND.
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM IS JUST
BEEN AND NOT GET INTO AND A
JEWEL IN OUR COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO LINK THOSE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT WE OFTEN DON'T GET
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE ANY
CONTACT WITH THEM THEY EITHER
ARE OFF TO COLLEGE OR THEIR OFF
A PLAYING VIDEO GAMES IN THEIR
IN THEIR BEDROOMS SOMEWHERE
BECAUSE THERE'S THAT DISENGAGED
SO THIS PUTS US IN TOUCHWITH
THEM EARLY ON IN THE JUNIOR HIGH
AND HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
AND WE SEE THAT THIS IS GONNA BE
A GREAT MATCH FOR US THE ONE OF
THESE DAYS THE ECONOMY WILL TAKE
A LITTLE DOWNTURN AND WE WANT TO
BE PREPARED TO THAT WE'VE GOT
THE STUDENTS WE'VE GOT HIM
TRAINED.
WE GOT EMPLOYERS THAT ARE MORE
THAN WILLING TO PICK UP THIS
PACE.
WE APPRECIATE YOU HELPING TO
KICK THIS OFF TO MAKE THESE
FUNDS AVAILABLE AND THEN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WILL PICK IT
UP AFTER THAT I APPRECIATE THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ASIDE.
THANK YOU.
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS RAJ HAVE YEAR
I'M WITH THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNARDINO SPEAKING ON ITEM
SIXTY SIX AS WELL.
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MY CALL IN
AND SEE GROUP HERE TODAY YES WE
DO AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES -- THE THE PROGRAM
THAT WERE REALLY TRYING TO
LAUNCH YOUR ENGINE GENERATION
GOES ARE INCREDIBLY DESTRUCTIVE
PROGRAM BUT IT FROM A COUNTY
WIDE PERSPECTIVE WE'RE LOOKING
TO WERE SEEKING TO SERVE BOTH
OUR BUSINESSES.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE SEE
THIS AS AN AVENUE FOR US TO
REALLY DISRUPT COMMUNITIES AND
REALLY RAISE THE TIGHT SORT OF
RISE TO TIED TO RISING TIDE
LIFTS ALL BOATS -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT -- MY COLLEAGUES DID
NOT SAY IS WE STARTED WITH ONE
OF THE MOST DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
AND WE'RE SHOWING OUT COMES WITH
THE WITH THE THESE COMMUNITIES
SOME OF THE STUDENTS HAVE COME
FROM LONG GENERATIONS OF FAMILY
HISTORIES OF NO ONE ATTENDING OR
THINKING A EVEN ABOUT COLLEGE
AND WE'RE SEEING.
COLLEGE GOING RATES INCREASE IN
COLLEGE.
THE THE PURSUIT OF FURTHERING
EDUCATION INCREASED AND THESE
KIDS ARE GETTING JBS.
AS THE COUNTY OF SAN BERNIE DINO
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
SIGNED ON TO THIS PROGRAM AND
DECIDED THAT WE REALIZE IT BUT
THAT NO STUDENT GROWS UP HOPING
TO WORK FOR THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNIE DINO SO WE NEEDED TO
ESTABLISH OUR OWN PIPELINES AS
WELL.
AND SO WE DECIDED THAT WE ARE
GOING TO PUT ASIDE MONIES SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE ON A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY KIDS THIS YEAR.
THE RESULTS OF THAT PROBE THAT
THAT IN THAT PART OF A PILOT
PROGRAM IS ARE PHENOMENAL WE'RE
ACTUALLY CONTINUING OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE OUR INTENT IS.
TO HOPEFULLY BRING THEM INTO THE
COUNTY AS REAL VIBRANT TALENT
AND THESE ARE KIDS ONCE AGAIN
FROM VERY DISTRESSED COMMUNITIES
AND WE HAVE EVEN TESTED THIS
WITH.
THE CONTINUATION SCHOOL SO WE
SEE THIS AS A FACET OF SERVING
THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO INVOLVE
IT IF YOU IMAGINE WHAT TEN YEARS
FROM NOW THESE KIDS ARE ALL
GOING TO BE PROFESSIONALS IN
THEIR OWN RIGHT IN THEIR OWN
CAREERS.
AND THEY'RE LIVING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE COMMUNITIES AT
THAT POINT SO WE SEE THIS AS
COMMUNITY SERVING AND BUSINESS
ENGAGEMENT AND AND WE'LL ALL IN.
ONE SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND THIS ITEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
TIME I'M HERE TO SUPPORT ITEM --
SIXTY SIX DO YOU HAVE HEARD OF
EVERYBODY TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAM
AND I AM THE RESULT OF WHAT
GENERATION GO BRINGS TO THE
TABLE -- I WILL I STARTED OFF
WITH THE VALLEY COLLEGE CLASS IN
SUMMER SEVENTY FIVE HOURS.
IT TOOK ME ON THAT GOT ME A
WORKFORCE READINESS CERTIFICATE
THAT TEACHES OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SKILLS THAT WE NEED TO
HELP FOR ANY JOB.
THEN AFTER THAT SECOND SEMESTER
SENIOR YEAR I GOT A PLACE IN A
JOB CALLED SORENSON ENGINEERING
IT'S A MICROMACHINING NEXT
COMPANY.
AND THEY ARE PLACING YOU CUT
BOTH RIGHT NEARBY WHERE I LIVE.
AND THROUGH THAT COMPANY I DID A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOURS WITH OF
BUT ON THE JOB EXPERIENCE AND I
DID OVER A HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH
OF QUALITY CONTROL.
JUST THROUGH THE INTERNSHIP.
I ALSO DREW MY PROGRAM THROUGH
THE PROGRAM I HAVE A NAME
CERTIFICATION IT'S THE NATIONAL
RECOGNIZE THE TICKET THAT SAYS --
I AM CAPABLE OF NAM SAFETY AND
MEASUREMENTS IS NAMES NAME
CERTIFICATIONS -- I ALSO HAVE
VALLEY COLLEGE CREDIT.
IT'S GOING TO HELP ME GET THE
LEG UP IN AND THE COLORS THAT I
TO TO GO.
TO AFTER I FINISHED MY ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOURS I GOT
OFFERED A JOB. FOR TOOLING AND I
GOT ACCEPTED FOR THE JOB.
I NOW WORK WITH THE MICROSCOPIC
MACHINE THAT WORKS ON
MICROSCOPIC TOOLS AND THEY HELP.
AND IT'S GETTING ME
MANUFACTURING EXPERIENCE AND THE
TECHNICAL.
EDUCATION THAT I NEED FOR THE
MANUFACTURING EDUCATION THAT I
WANT TO GET SO I'M GOING TO NOW
GO TO CAL POLY POMONA -- TO GET
A MANUFACTURING ENGINEERING
DEGREE.
AND I'M THE RESULT OF GENERATION
GO AND SIX SIX THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS.
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON ON ALL
THE STEPS THAT YOU'RE TAKING TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
CHARTER OTHERS SENATOR UMBERG --
I'M HERE ON ITEM -- FORTY ONE
INSTEAD ANA AND MICHAEL SIR AGO
SOME BEHALF IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS -- WE
SUPPORT THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION --
FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT STEPS --
TOWARD COMBATING THAT PROBLEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WOULD CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
GIVES HERE ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER
OF BAY AREA CITIES ON ITEM
NUMBER -- FORTY THE FOLLOWING
CITIES ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HOMELESSNESS FUNDING AND
ITEM FORTY THE CITIES OF OAKLAND.
CITY OF BERKELEY CITY OF
EMERYVILLE AS WELL AS THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES OF DANVILLE DUBLIN
TEN DUBLIN PLEASANTON LIVERMORE
IN SAN RAMON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M SURE SENATOR UMBERG -- HERE
ISSUE FORTY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
SO SEATED BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS
OF STRONG SUPPORT TO FOREIGN
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR UMBERG
JEREMY SMITH HERE BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION TODAY ONLY.
OF AND IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER.
FORTY ONE THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT WILL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS CREATING.
THOUSANDS OF NEW JOBS -- FIXING
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
AND HELPING THE ENVIRONMENT YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR CENTER ON BURDEN I'M
HERE ON ITEM ISSUE SEVENTY FIVE
CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
MY NAME IS JORDAN LINDSAY AND
THE SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND UNITED THROUGH WILL PULL THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE -- I
WILL BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU A
MOMENT JUST TO GET TO IT.
IF YOU LIKE.
QUESTION ITEM WITH THE IF YOU
WANNA IS IT WAIT TILL THAT YEAH
OKAY.
YES WE CAN YOU CAN COME UP AND
SPEAK ON IT LATER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IN THE
STATE'S OUR CULTURE -- AND ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
FORTY ONE CENTER BILLS OF FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY ANGER MAY SALIH OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM SIXTY FOUR SO
THAT WORKERS WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY UNDER UTILIZED THE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM CAN
PARTICIPATE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON AND YOU
KNOW WHY THE HEART WHILE A OR P.
CALIFORNIA WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET ASKED TO EXPAND
OUR REACH ON PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
NOT ONLY IS THERE UNDER
UTILIZATION OF THIS PROGRAM THAT
WORKERS PAY INTO ESPECIALLY
AMONG CARE GIVERS FOR OLDER AND
DISABLED ADULT FAMILY MEMBERS.
THE UTILIZATION -- DEFINITELY
NEEDS IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE DO
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ASKED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI JANNA CARLSON
ACTING LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
THREE THAT WOULD ELIMINATE TO
FEES WITH REGARD TO TAX EXEMPT.
ORGANIZATIONS THE TAX EXEMPT
APPLICATION FEE AND THE ANNUAL
FORM ONE NINETY NINE FILING FEE.
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCY
AND EASE OF TAXPAYER BURDEN.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
AND I'M SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM -- FORTY THREE
FUNDING FOR HOMELESS YOUTH --
FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT THE
pDEFINITELY NEED MORE AND
SYSTEMIC RESPONSE -- TO YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THESE
FUNDS WILL BE A STEP FORWARD TO
ALLOWING OUR COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP THT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS RANDY LAROCHE I'M A PROUD
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIAN BUT
THE HISTORY OF SPEAKING IN
SACRAMENTO ON BEHALF OF MY
FORMER UNION A FEW TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE WHEN I WAS WORKING IN
THE COMMUNICATIVE STRICT.
I'M SINCE RETIRED AND I'M
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF ITEM.
THIRTY THE LGBT PERFORMING ARTS
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'VE BEEN AFFILIATED WITH GAY
MEN'S CHORUS FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS AND I SAW ALMOST THE VERY
BEGINNING WHEN WE BUT FOR HERS
IN THE HIGH SCHOOL AUDITORIUM IF
WE COULD GET SPACE LIKE THAT AT
ALL.
I'VE SEEN AS THROUGH THE UPS AND
DOWNS THAT WORSE FOR THE AIDS
EPIDEMIC FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
WE HAVE ALWAYS MANAGED TO STICK
TOGETHER GALVANIZED THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY WE HAVE GROWN TO BE
ACCEPTED WE WE ARE WELL KNOWN.
HAVING THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
OWN PERFORMING ARTS CENTER.
WHICH WE CAN SHARE WITH MANY
OTHER GROUPS.
WILL HELP UNTOLD THOUSANDS OF
MUSICIANS PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
PLEASE STRONGLY CONSIDER ARE
ASKING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I'M DAVID LOUDEN AND YET
YOU'RE NOT SEEING DOUBLE THAT'S
MY HUSBAND HAD.
HE IS.
GOING.
TO AND I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU
ABOUT MY FAVORITE PROGRAM WITH
THE CHORUS AND THAT'S RHYTHM
THAT REACHING YOU THROUGH MUSIC.
AT THE INVITATION OF LOCAL BAY
AREA SCHOOLS FORTY TO FIFTY
CHORUS MEMBERS WILL HOLD A
WORKSHOP.
WE WILL SING SONGS OF HOPE AND
INSPIRATION AND BELONGING -- FEW
MEMBERS WILL TELL THEIR COMING
OUT STORIES.
WE HAVE A QUESTION AND ANSWER
AND IT REALLY.
MEANS A LOT TO THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE IT LETS THEM KNOW THEY'RE
NOT ALONE YEAH BUT THEY BELONG.
AND THAT THEY CAN BE THEIR
AUTHENTIC SELVES.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE COULD
EXPAND THAT BEYOND THE BAY AREA
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE SHOULD
HAVE YOU PERFORM.
YEAH.
IT RE ENOUGH HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON.
FACT TO FOLLOW THEIR MY NAME IS
MICHAEL A ROCK IN THE CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
PAUL AND I'M HERE AND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY NINE A REQUEST FROM
SENATOR JACKSON TO FUND.
SOME REPAIRS FOR THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB BUILDING THAT THE
CITY OWNS AND BY ME IS JAN WHO
OPERATES THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB.
PROGRAMMING.
THE BUILDING IS WAS BUILT IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES NEEDS SERIOUS
REPAIRS TO THE ROOF PLUMBING
RESTROOMS -- PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING -- WE'RE VERY EXCITED
TO BE HERE FROM SANTA PAULA.
AND WOOD -- REQUEST THE SUPPORT
ITEM SIXTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU IT TO CLOSE DOWN VERY
LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM THE CEO
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB FOR
SANTA CLARA VALLEY -- THIS IS
THE FACE OF THE KIDS THAT WE
SERVE WERE IN 93% HISPANIC --
ALL OUR KIDS ARE AT RISK IN
UNDERSERVED.
CAN.
YOU KNOW I WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ELEMENTARY PRINCIPAL TO TAKE
OVER.
THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB SEVEN
YEARS AGO BECAUSE THEY NEED
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR
BUILDING.
IS SO OLD THAT THIS YEAR INDOOR
BASKETBALL WAS OBSTACLE COURSE
FROM ALL THE BUCKETS THAT WERE
THEY ARE HOLDING THE RAIN -- THE
BATHROOMS ARE HORRIBLE YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN TOUCHED IN OVER
SIXTY YEARS I PULLED ONE URINAL
OUT BECAUSE OF SO MANY MARBLES.
AND THEN -- THE HEARING GOES
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT UNDER THE
TILE IT NEEDS TO BE GUIDED.
ON THESE ARE OLD BUILDINGS WE
STAND BACK THE DOORS THE SIDES
OF TE DOORS AND THE WATER STILL
COMES AND I MEAN.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE DO AN
AMAZING JOB WITH OUR KIDS ARE
SETBACK IS OUR FACILITY A ON
IT'S NOT JUST OUR BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB WHEN WERE CLOSED AT NIGHT
IN ON THE WEEKENDS.
THE CITY YOUTH LEAGUES COMMAND
AND THEY PLAY BASKETBALL AND IF
IT'S NCUMBENT WHETHER WE LET
BASEBALL COME IN AND THEY CAN
PRACTICE YOU KNOW IN THERE SO
IT'S USED BY THE WHOLE COMMUNITY
NOT JUST OUR BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
IN SO -- RESPECTFULLY I I ASK
THAT YOU REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT
NUMBER -- SIXTY NINE BUT SENATOR
JACKSON'S -- REQUESTED THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ANTI YOUR WORK
PRECIADO THANK YOU.
HELLO PRIMARY MCCABE AND I'M AN
ORIGINAL MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GAY MEN'S CHORUS.
AND I HELP FORM THE COURSE BY
PUTTING UP FLYERS TO ATTRACT
SINGERS.
HI AS A MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GAY FREEDOM DAY
MARCHING BAND THE TOOLING COR.
IT'S NO IT'S NO COINCIDENCE THAT
WE STARTED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IT WAS
SAN FRANCISCO'S GAY COMMUNITIES --
NEED TO UNITE AND DO WHATEVER WE
COULD TO FIGHTING THE BRIDGE
BREAKS INITIATIVE PROPOSITION
SIX THAT YEAR.
SO WE WERE BORN IN OUT OF OUR
NEED TO DO WHAT WE COULD DO IN
OUR CASE MUSICALLY. TO THAT MAKE
A STATEMENT AND COME TOGETHER
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW FORTY ONE YEARS LATER.
CREATING THIS LGBT OUR CENTER
FOR THE ARTS.
IN OUR HOME IN SAN FRANCISCO OUR
NEW BUILDING AND MAKING IT SO WE
CAN MOVE THIS FORWARD KEEP IT
GOING.
THEY'RE STILL UNFORTUNATELY A
BIG NEED FOR US TO MAKE OUR
MUSIC TOGETHER AND TO PUSHED
MOVEMENT FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BEING THE PIONEER.
GOOD MORNING GERMAN LAW FIRM
SENATOR UMBERG ON JUNGLE ISLAND
I'M HERE ON ITEM THIRTY THE
NATIONAL LGBTQ CENTER FOR THE
ARTS.
I CAN'T SAYINGS WILL SPEAK TO
THE BUSINESS SIDE OF THAT -- THE
I AM REALLY HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO REPRESENT THE NATIONAL CENTER
IT IS CALLED THE NATIONAL CENTER
EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN LOS
ANGELES SUPERVISOR SHE LOOK
YOU'LL MAYOR TERRACE STEINBERG
FROM SACRAMENTO.
THIS IS TRULY SOMETHING FOR ALL
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOT JUST
ASKING FOR A BUDGET ALLOCATION
WERE ASKING FOR AN INVESTMENT.
BUT THIS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS I ASSURE YOU ABLE IT
WILL.
ENGAGE TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
PRIVATE FUNDING SO IT'S A
INVESTMENT THAT WILL LEAD TO
WHAT WE WILL DO TWO HUNDRED
TIMES WHAT THIS -- INVESTMENT IS
AND THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN THE
RUSSELL AND CENTER ON BURKE MY
NAME IS MY SAYS GARCIA I'M A SAN
FRANCISCO RIGHT AS PRESIDENT AND
ORIGINALLY HAIL FROM NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY -- HERE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE THIRTY I
CURRENTLY WORK FOR THE GAY MEN'S
CHORUS BUT MY PREVIOUS JOB I HAD
THE HONOR OF WORKING FOR THE
CENSUS BECAUSE OF THE NO
CULTURAL DISTRICT.
BY RETURNING A MYRIAD OF
CULTURAL ARTS ORGANIZATIONS WE
WERE TASKED WITH PRESERVING AND
PROTECTING THE CALL TWO OUT OF
THE MISSION DISTRICT.
WE HAD MANY SUCCESSES BUT WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD A TRAGIC LOSS
WHEN GONNA GET THAT LET US --
FORTY YEAR OLD COMMITTEE
INSTITUTION LOS IT'S HOME
DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS WITH
CITY PARTNERS FOUNDATIONS AND
REALLY HOWEVER WE CAN GET.
GOING -- I MENTION THIS BECAUSE
IT'S A CRITICAL TIME IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR NONPROFITS THAT
PARTICULARLY FOR CULTURE ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS -- WE'RE REALLY
BEING SQUEEZED BY RISING COSTS
TO BOTH -- HE PRODUCED IN OUR
PROGRAMMING AS WELL AS RISING
COSTS FOR SPACE -- AND THAT THIS
BUT THERE'S GO I'M REALLY
THRILLED THAT SENSIBLE GAY MEN'S
CHORUS IS USING THEIR POWER AND
THEIR STRENGTH TO LIFT UP OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AND
CALIFORNIA -- THIS IS A SPACE IN
THE VISION TO BRING IN.
MULTIPLE ARTISTS ARTISTS --
DANCERS WHAT HAVE YOU THEATER
PERFORMERS TO COME TO COME TO A
SPACE BILL TO PERFORM PRACTICE
AND PRODUCE THEIR ARTISTIC WORK.
THE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ITEM THIRTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR THE
RATHER GOOD AFTERNOON.
CENTER NUMBER GOT MY NAME'S
CHRIS FOR GOING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GAY MEN'S CHORUS AND THE
NATIONAL TO BE SECURE CENTER FOR
THE ARTS -- I'VE HERE SPEAKING
ON ITEM THIRTY AND I ACTUALLY AT
THE PLEASURE OF PROVIDING PUBLIC
COMMENT ABOUT A MONTH AGO FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
ON SO I WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE AS
YOU SEE I HAVE A CADRE OF PEOPLE
BEFORE ME WHO HAVE DONE REALLY
THE YEOMAN'S WORK -- WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT LAUNCHING THE
NATIONAL TO BE T. Q. ARTS CENTER.
IT WILL BRING TOGETHER
COMMUNITIES FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. ARTS AND
ARTISTS TO COLLABORATE TO
INCUBATE NEW WORKS IT REALLY
MOVE FORWARD THE MOVE THE NEEDLE
FOR FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
REALLY -- PROVIDE A SPACE WHERE
WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND AS TOM
SAID EARLIER AT THE AT THE AT
THE START OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT --
I WAS A YOUNG MAN AND FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD DEMAND THE FLORIDA --
AND THAT WAS SOME OF THAT YEARS
AGO.
AND I HAD NO -- HAD I NOT HAD
MUSIC IN MY LIFE.
I WOULD NOT BE HERE AND THAT IS
NOT AN EXAGGERATION WE HAD NO
WELL T BE DQ CENTERS WE HAD NO
PLACE TO GALVANIZE NOT IN THE
BODY OF THAT I GREW UP IN -- SO
KNOWING NOW THAT IN SOME WAYS
THINGS HAVE CHANGED -- MASTIC
DRASTICALLY -- AND DRAMATICALLY
AND FOR THE GOOD -- I ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LACK OF OF MUSIC
EDUCATION AND REALLY MUSIC IN
SCHOOLS WHICH PROVIDE THAT SPACE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO COME
TOGETHER AND REALLY THRIVE.
AND SUPER PROVIDE AN OUTLET FOR
THEM TO TRULY BE AN EXPRESS WHO
THEY ARE SO WE HOPE TO BE THAT
SPACE THANKS SAN FRANCISCO BUT
NOT JUST FOR THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO REALLY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR COMING
THANK YOU.
HI CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX GIVES
ME AFTER NUMBER BAY AREA CITIES
I WAS JUST BEFORE YOU A MOMENT
AGO I APOLOGIZE FOR MISS
SPEAKING ON THE ITEM NUMBER IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ITEM NUMBER
FORTY TWO AS OPPOSED TO ITEM
NUMBER.
FORTY AND THAT IS BEHALF OF
STRONG SUPPORT WE HAVE TO SEIZE
OF OAKLAND BERKELEY EMERYVILLE
THE TRI VALLEY CITIES A DAB.
DANVILLE DUBLIN PLEASANT IN
LIVERMORE IN SAN RAMON THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THE GERMAN DRUG DRUG SO AND
NUMBER -- THIS IS I'M GENYA
CASSIDY AND I'M WITH THE STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER -- SIXTY
FOUR AT JACKSON'S BUDGET REQUEST
FOR PAID FAMILY FUNDING FOR OUR
REGION EDUCATION FOR PAID FAMILY
LEAVE WE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
SINCE THE VERY BEGINNING WHEN
THE FIRST LAW PASSED AND WE KNOW
THAT. ONE OF THE FIRST BARRIERS
THAT -- CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES FACE TO TAKING
PAID FAMILY LEAVE IS LOW
AWARENESS ESPECIALLY IN LOW
INCOME -- LIMóN NEW WORKER IS
LATINO NEW IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND
WE ARE I'M HERE TO REALLY WORK
WITH THE EDT ON EXPANDING OUT
REGION EDUCATION AS WERE MAKING --
PAID FAMILY LEAVE WORK FOR MORE
WORKERS THANK YOU THANKS VERY
MUCH.
WELL MADAM CHAIR AS CENTER
NUMBER GOT TRENT LYING PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN --
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
THIRTY SIX OPEN PAPER OPEN
SOURCE PAPER BALLOT VOTING
SYSTEM -- THE URGENCY OF THIS
ISSUE IS ILLUSTRATED.
BY THE MALL THE REPORT WHO'S
VERY FIRST SENTENCE WAS THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT INTERFERED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN GENERAL
ELECTION AND SWEEPING SYSTEMIC
FASHION.
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOUND THAT -- THE RUSSIANS --
ATTEMPTED TO GET INTO OUR LEASE
RESEARCH -- ELECTION SYSTEMS IN
ALL FIFTY STATES PROBLEMS THAT
OUR CURRENT ELECTION SYSTEMS.
USING SECRET PROPRIETARY
SOFTWARE ARE VERY INSECURE AT
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DEF
CON SECURITY CONFERENCE IN LAS
VEGAS THEY FOUND THAT EVERY
SINGLE SYSTEM WAS BREACHED IN
SOME MANNER AND CALLED IT A
NATIONAL SECURITY RISK.
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD DO WITH
EIGHT CALIFORNIA TO LEAD --
THOUGHT TO COUNTIES LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
ALREADY WORKING ON THIS TO
DEVELOP A MORE SECURE IN
TRANSPARENT OPEN SOURCE.
PAPER BALLOT VOTING SYSTEMS ARE
BETTER MORE TRANSPARENT AND THAT
THAT WILL BE MORE TRUSTWORTHY --
TO TO THE PUBLIC -- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THOSE
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY -- ON THE REQUEST -- IT
WOULD AID THEM IN DRAMATICALLY
MAKING THE SYSTEMS FASTER AND
WOULD SAY BUDGET FUNDS IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE THEN WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO PAY THE PROPRIETARY
SOFTWARE FEES SO WOULD SAVE
ACTUALLY HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ONCE AS DIRECTED SO WE
WOULD URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
UMBERG MY NAME IS WESLEY SEVERAL
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM.
FORTY THREE BY INVESTING IN
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS PREVENTS
ADULT CHRONICLE MISSUS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO ALL OF THESE THANK YOU FOR TO
EVERYBODY WHO CAME SOMEBODY FROM
LONG DISTANCES.
NEXT TIME WE'RE GONNA EXPECTED
PERFORMANCE.
THAT WOULD MAKE IT MORE FUN YOU
GOTTA ADMIT.
YOU CAN SAYING ALL OF THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
EVERYBODY WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO
ISSUE [inaudible]
SEVENTY ONE THE OKAY.
THIS IS THE SENATE HOUSING.
AND HOMELESS FRAMEWORK.
JUST AS A REMINDER OF WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED.
A TWO POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE IN HIS JANUARY
BUDGET.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS TODAY
[inaudible]
OF FIRST OF THE FRAMER PROVIDES
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
THIS COMING YEAR FOR HOUSING
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT.
THIS INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN GRANTS TO REGIONS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. FOR SUPORT
OF THE SIXTH.
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT CYCLE THAT IS JUST
NOW BEGINNING OKAY SO -- THIS
ONE HERE.
ADDITIONALLY THE FRAMEWORK
PROVIDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT'S WHAT WE ADDED OR AMENDED --
IN NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
WILL BE DIRECTED TO HOUSING
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THE OUT YEARS FUNDING WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH A NEW
STATUTORY VEHICLE AGREED TO BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
SO THE SECOND PART IS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
OF THE SIX HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WILL BE DIRECTED TO THE
THIRTEENTH LARGEST CITIES IN THE
STATE.
AND THE REMAINING FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION WILL SUPPORT CONTINUUM
OF CARE ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS FUND THE WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED LAST YEAR.
AS PART OF THIS EFFORT WE'VE
ALSO ADDED -- COMPOSED TO
CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
INCLUDING STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
STATE WIDE POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS ON A
LONG TERM BASIS.
AND LAST THE FRAMEWORK PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
THIS INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS AND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR CAL
HF ETS MIXED INCOME LOAN PROGRAM.
THE FRAMEWORK OF ADDITIONALLY IT
PROVIDES A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN INNOVATIVE
FINANCING TOOLS.
BOB FOR EXAMPLE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AN AD YOU FINANCING
PROGRAM.
AT CAL H. FAA. FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE FOR PROPERTIES
RELATED -- TO THESEVEN TEN UP
PROJECT THROUGH A PROJECT.
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RECYCLED UNDER
UTILIZED SITES PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES GRANTS FOR BROWN FIELD
REMEDIATION AND DEVELOPMENT.
AS PART OF THE PROPOSAL WE WILL
ADOPT PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROPOSED PROGRAMS.
THIS FRAMEWORK IS SUMMARIZED ON
PAGE THIRTY THREE OF THE AGENDA.
THIS REPRESENTS THE SENATE'S
PRIORITIZATION OF THE ISSUES OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS.
AND OUR DETERMINATION TO TACKLE
THEM IN A ROBUST WAY.
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE --
MEMBERS.
OF QUESTIONS NO.
OKAY NOW WE WILL TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
AGAIN PLEASE.
KEEP YOUR TIME.
SHORT SO THAT WE COULD HAVE
EVERYBODY -- SPEAK GO AHEAD
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
FIRST WE ARE EXTREMELY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FRAMEWORK
STAFF'S TIME AND ALL OF THE
EFFORT PUT INTO THE FRAMEWORK
FOR SUPPORTIVE OF THE ADDITIONAL
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS FUNDING --
WE URGE ON THE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING THAT EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN POINT IN TIME COUNTY
UTILIZED AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING DEEPER INTO
THE DETAILS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS THANK YOU.
HOLD ON TO SOMETHING
.
BOB JUST JUST [inaudible]
TO PERHAPS.
GUIDE YOUR COMMENTS IN A MOMENT
I'M GONNA MAKE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE SENATE FRAMEWORK
ADOPT PLEASE HOLD TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. TO IMPLEMENT THE
FRAMEWORK SO IF IT WAS TALK ME
OUT OF IT THEY SHOULD SPEAK TO
THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S KEVIN GILL WHO
LEAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR IN CENTER I'M BURKE -- I'M
I'M THE LEGISLATION MANAGER AT
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS I'M
HERE TO SPEAK AN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE INTO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I'M BRING FOR YOUR
MOTION.
THE HOUSING A HOMELESS FRAMEWORK
PROPOSES TO PROVIDE REGION'S
WITH FUNDING TO HELP CITIES
COUNTIES AND OTHER REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS TO THINK
STRATEGICALLY AND CREATIVELY.
ABOUT HOW TO ACCOMMODATE AND
WELCOME NEW HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR REGION'S.
PHYSICALLY THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE SHARED BY
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS LIKE SKAGGS.
TO CONDUCT FEASIBILITY STUDIES
AND SPECIFIC PLANS PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
JURISDICTIONS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ROBUST HOUSING STAFF OF THEIR
OWN.
IN TO PERFORM REGIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING. TO HELP
IDENTIFY THE MOST APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS FOR NEW HOUSING.
THESE PLANNING DOLLARS WILL
PROVIDES GAG WITH THE ABILITY TO
OFFER ENHANCED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR ONE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE CITIES AND SIX
COUNTIES. TO UPDATE THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENTS TO ACCOMMODATE
AND WELCOME NEW HOUSING BUT
HELPING THE STATE ALSO TO
ACHIEVE OTHER CRITICAL POLICY
GOALS.
SUCH AS IDENTIFYING INITIATIVES
THAT AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING REDUCE HEAT TRAPPING
GREENHOUSE GASES AND REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
AN INSURED RAZA AND CENTER ON
BURKE AGAIN SUPPORTING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER X. MOTION PAT
WHALEN ELSE MOST NEVER SEE HERE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO SO SHE
HAS A SAVE SUPERPOSITION
GOVERNMENTS AND ACT.
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE IT IN IN THE PLANNING
ASSISTANCE FUNDING TO BE SPLIT
BETWEEN THE COGS AND THE LOCALS
THAT'SGONNA HELP US BECAUSE
WE'RE STARTING OUR SIX THREE IN
A CYCLE IN AS PART OF THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SETTING THE
STAGE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND NEW
YOU UNITS OF HOUSING WHICH IS AN
AMBITIOUS 45% INCREASE OVER OUR
OUR CURRENT PLAN -- IN ADDITION
CERTAIN SEVERAL EFFORTS ARE
UNDER WAY IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION TO FACILITATE THE
PRODUCTION FOR HOUSING WE HAD
LOTS OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
STREAMLINING THE PERMIT PROCESS --
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S OPPOSED ROLE FOR THE
COGS.
AS PART OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IN HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE HOPE THAT THE FINAL
FRAMEWORK -- THAT'S AGREED UPON
ALLOWS FOR REGIONAL AGENCIES
LIKE SAND I'D HAVE A ROLE IN
THAT PROCESS THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I'M SURE WERE US A NUMBER OF
MIKE MOLLY GONNA BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IS TO SAY THAT THE
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS. NINE
COUNTIES ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
CITIES VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT
RIPPLES.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR SENATOR UMBERG JEAN
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
I REALLY WANT TO EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THEIR CONSIDERABLE
TIME AND EFFORT ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER.
WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT --
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS --
THE HOMELESS AB AT CRISIS THAT
WE ARE FACING LOCALLY.
WE APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT THE STRUCTURE PROVIDES
LOCALS TO ADDRESS -- COMMUNITY
NEEDS ON AND ON A UNIQUE BASIS --
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE USE OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT DATA AS THE MECHANISM FOR
I'M DEVELOPING ALLOCATIONS.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
CONTINUED DIALOGUE OBVIOUSLY
AFTER TODAY ON THEIR BE
CONSIDERABLE CONVERSATION SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS THUS FAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHANNA ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT THIS
CENTER FOR CREATIVELY AND
RECYCLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE --
SEVENTY ONE SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDING THE FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
IT AT THE NEW MADAM CHAIRMAN
SENATOR UMBERG MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE THANK YOU FOR ON THIS-PROPOSAL AND AND FOR THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE SPENT -- WITH THE
WITH THE CONSULTANT -- TAKES
INTO CONSIDERATION WHAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED AND AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE -- TO LOOK AT THE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL WHICH
IS A SLIGHT VARIATION AND THE
ASSEMBLY SO THAT WE CAN -- BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR HOMELESS
AND SIGNIFICANT HOMELESS NEEDS
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AFTERNOON CAN LESS AGAIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
THAN PLEASE SAYS SEE THE
FRAMEWORK BEFORE US TODAY AND
FOR YOUR STAFF'S ATTENTION TO
INCREASING THE ALLOCATION.
I'M SET ASIDE FOR YOU
SPECIFICALLY SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT YOUR STAFF'S ATTENTION I'M
AND WE WOULD WELCOME TO BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION AROUND THE
STRATEGY OF ARE AND HOW TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS IN THE LONG TERM.
I'M SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY [inaudible]
FIRST VOLUNTEER.
SPARKY HARLAN CEO BILL WILSON
CENTER AGAIN AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AS I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
IN OUR POINT IN TIME ACCOUNT.
40% OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
ARE USED SO FOR USE THE PIT
COUNT WE WOULD GET 40% OF THAT
MONEY WHILE WE APPRECIATE 10%
SET ASIDE FOR YOU.
AND LOS ANGELES SANDIEGO AND
SANTA CLARA IT'S MUCH HIGHER
THAN 10% SO WE WOULD ASK 410%.
OR AT THE PIT COUNT FOR YOU
WHICHEVER IS LARGER AS PART OF
THE FRAMEWORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY MUCH.
HI AGAIN CHERYL ADAMS ARE
CONCEIVED SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND BOARD CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH SPEAKING IN FAOR AND
SUPPORT OF ITEMS SEVENTY ONE AND
IN PARTICULAR THE FOCUS ON YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THE ATTENTION TO
REALLY LOOK AT THE 10%.
ALLOCATION IT'S IT'S JUST
FABULOUS TO SEE ATTENTION BEING
FOCUSED ON YOUTH AFTER A LONG
HARD FIGHT FOR THAT SO THANK YOU --
AND AS KIM SAID WE'D A WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THE
STRATEGY CONVERSATION THANKS
THANK YOU.
I CRISTINA LUCKY WITH THE
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS ANA ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY FELLOW KALRA
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU FOR THE FREE MORE
PARTICULARLY IN AREA ONE HOUSING
PLANNING AND PRODUCTION -- WE
AND SACRAMENTO HAVE A BIG FOCUS
ON NOT ONLY HOUSING PRODUCTION
BUT BEING OCCASIONALLY EFFICIENT
AND HOW WE DO OUR HOUSING AND
MAKING SURE WE'RE NOT GOING
OUTWARD.
AND SPREADING OUTWARD BUT IN
FACT HAVING MORE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND SO THAT'S KEY
ROLE THAT THE **** PLATE WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
LOCALLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR JURISDICTIONS ARE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ON HOW WE CAN
ACCELERATE UNTIL WE DEVELOP
AGREED MEANS GO PROGRAM TO DO
THAT THE ONE OF THE KEY BARRIERS
THAT WE'RE FACING IS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE WHEN I
THINK YOU FOR DIRECTING NOT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION. TO THE IG
PROGRAM WHICH WILL GO A LONG WAY
IN OUR REGION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MAN CHAIR ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRYL STAMBERG CROSS WHICH
HERE'S THE BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION.
THE MAYOR SUPPORT THE DASCHLE
FUNDING THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE
SENSE FRAMEWORK BUT WE CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR A FIFTY FIFTY
SPLIT BETWEEN THE CITIES AND THE
CEO SEES.
A YESTERDAY THE BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION ALONG WITH A BROAD
BASE OF HOUSING ADVOCATES PUT
FORTH A JOINT BUDGET REQUEST --
IN THAT REQUEST INCLUDE A ONE
BILLION -- ONE TEN ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS SPLIT FIFTY FIFTY BETWEEN
THE CITIES AND THE CEO SEES HELP
ADDRESS HOMES ISSUES -- AND I'M
GOING OUT TO SHOW FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR FOR THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
ADDITION THE MAYORS IN THE
COALITION SUPPORT GRANT PROGRAM
TO ADDRESS -- HELP USERS ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
PASSAGE OF FUNDING FOR A BI
THREE OF SEVEN AND FINALLY THE
MAYOR SUPPORT INVESTING GRANTS
TO COUNTIES AND CITIES WHO HAVE
EXISTING WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS.
AND FUNDING FOR QUICKLY
IMPORTANT PREVENTION AND LEGAL
SERVICES INCLUDING CENTER SCARES
SB EIGHTEEN THANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING -- WE ALSO SUPPORT
INCREASE INVESTMENT AND USE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WAS
GLAD TO SEE THAT THE FRAMEWORK.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS AND
I GUESS I MAYBE.
I'M GOING TO TRY AND TALK YOU
OUT OF ADOPTING THE FRAMEWORK
AROUND THE HOMELESS PROVISIONS
AS A WHOLE -- WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM.
WE DO SEE HOMELESSNESS IS A
CRISIS WITH -- OVER NINE HUNDRED
PEOPLE DYING ON THE STREETS OF
LOS ANGELES ALONE LAST YEAR --
WE THINK OF HOMELESSNESS IS A
MORAL CRISIS DECADES IN THE
MAKING THAT WILL TAKE --
COMPREHENSIVE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS -- AND WE DO NOT
THINK THAT A TEMPORARY EMERGENCY
RESPONSE THROUGH THE HOMELESS
EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM IS THE
RIGHT RESPONSE.
I WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO BEGIN A
DIALOGUE AND WOULD LOVE TO BEGIN
THE BILL BE PART OF THAT
DIALOGUE AROUND A COMPREHENSIVE
RESPONSE.
WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT WORKS TO
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS WE KNOW FROM --
LOTS OF RESEARCH DECADES OF
RESEARCH AND AND WHAT HAS WORKED
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL -- AND
IT'S AND THERE'S NO TIME LIKE
THE PRESENT ACTUALLY BEGIN TO
PUT SOME OF THOSE -- PROVEN
SOLUTIONS AND MOTIONS THIS YEAR --
AS JUST MENTION THE BIG CITY
MAYORS AND A COALITION OF OVER
SIXTY FIVE HOMELESS ADVOCATES
ARE PROPOSING AN INVESTMENT OF
ONE BILLION DOLLARS -- AND THIS
IS A LESS THAN ONE HALF OF 1% OF
OF THIS YEAR'S STATE BUDGET.
THE FLEXIBLE POOL FOR HOUSING
AND SERVICES BALANCES A CRISIS
RESPONSE WITH LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS PROVEN TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS -- THIS POOL IS THE
FIRST STEP IN THE STATE CAN TAKE
TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREET NOW
IT ALSO INCLUDES AGGRESSIVE TIME
LINES FOR GETTING THE MONEY OUT
QUICKLY -- AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT IS A STEP TOWARD A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE THIS YEAR
WITHOUT DELAYING IMPLEMENTING OF
WHAT WHAT WE NOW WORKS TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS SO I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL AS AN
ALTERNATIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FINALLY -- CHRIS MARTIN WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WANT TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS WHERE -- A PART OF THAT
COALITION -- WITH THE BIG CITY
MAYORS AND AND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ADVOCATES -- BUT
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED
FOR MORE LONG TERM.
APPROACH TO OUGHT TO
HOMELESSNESS GETTING PEOPLE INTO
HOUSING-- THE FLEXIBLE THAT WAS
MENTIONED IS A POOL THAT COULD
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
IMMEDIATELY BUT ALSO KEEP THEM
HOUSE ON THE LONG TERM SO WE
BELIEVE THAT'S A WAY TO SOLVE
BOTH OF THE THE NEEDS OF THE
IMMEDIATE NEED AND KEEP PEOPLE
HOUSE -- LONG TERM IN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO AND HOPE TO BE A PART
OF THE DISCUSSION AROUND A LONG
TERM SOLUTION THANKS.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SHOW UP AND THEN I HEARD WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS VERSUS ONE TIME FIXES --
THIS IS A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION THIS ISSUE IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY.
OF SOMETHING WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
FOR A LONG.
TIME -- HAVING SAID THAT I MOVE
TO APPROVE THE SENATE FRAMEWORK
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT FRAMEWORK
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SENATOR RAZA I NIELSEN SENATOR
UMBERG.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR COMING
[inaudible]
OKAY -- YEAH.
IN.
ORDER
.
ALL RIGHT SO [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO MADAM CHAIR -- IN ORDER FOR
FOLKS TO BUILD FOCUS THEIR
COMMENTS I WANT TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO AND
NUMBER -- SEVENTY THREE ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTY TWO OF ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS ALL HAVE IS.
HOW IT IS -- SIMILAR TO THE
CALIFORNIA JOB CHALLENGE ACADEMY
AT LASALLE MIDDLE SO VISITED
THAT LOCATION EXTREMELY
IMPRESSED.
SO IF YOU COULD COMMENT ON THAT --
I'M INCLINED TO SUPPORT BOTH
THOSE MEASURES SAUL LET YOU TALK
ME OUT OF THAT IF YOU'RE
INCLINED -- MAY BE EXPLAINED THE
SIMILARITIES AND THE MANAGER IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU WE'LL GO
FROM THERE.
SO.
YEAH -- WILL BE TIGHT ON TIME IN
TERMS OF THE ISSUES THAT NEED TO
VOTE SO.
WE WANNA MOVE FORWARD SO -- THE
NEXT ITEM IS THE DISCOVERY --
CHALLENGE ACADEMY EXPANSION OVER
ONE OUT WELCOME MADE GENERAL
BALDWIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE MAJOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR I AM A DEFAULT
ON ON THE EDGE IN GENERAL I RUN
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND IN
THE TO BE BRIEF ALL JUST ANSWER
CENTER IN BERKS QUESTION THE
PROGRAMS RIGHT DENTICLE SO WE
RUN THREE CHALLENGE PROGRAMS ONE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AT LOS
ALAMITOS.
WANNA CANCELLOUS MISSPOKE AND
THE WITH OUR NEWEST ONE IS THE
ONE THE DISCOVERY ONE THAT'S IN
A LATE THREATEN THAT SERVES THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BORDER UP FOR
OF EDUCATION.
SO AGAIN I'M I'M I'M INTERESTED
WHAT THE PER FINANCES SAY IN LA --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO VISIT THOSE
OTHER FACILITIES SO.
ADDING THAT CAVIAR -- LET IF YOU
DON'T MIND THAT I'M SURE WE'LL
HEAR FROM FINANCE AND LA -- AND
THEN [inaudible]
BEFORE.
THE LAST WORD PARTNER FINANCE WE
HAVE NOTHING THAT AT THE
STANFORD. FOR A FURTHER --
SEVENTY TWO PULLING HER TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THE
DISCOVERY CHALLENGE PROGRAM AS
YOU INDICATED ON THERE'S
ACTUALLY QUITE A BIT OF EVIDENCE
ON THAT PROGRAM AND WERE VERY
COMFORTABLE THAT PROPOSAL.
I'M WITH REGARD TO THE SECOND
PROPOSAL -- WITH REGARD TO THAT
JOB CHALLENGE PROGRAM -- WE
THINK IT'S VERY PROMISING THERE
BEEN A COUPLE OF PILOT PROGRAMS
THREE PILOT PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
DONE IN OTHER STATE.
OTHER STATES EXCUSE ME THERE'S
LIMITED DATA AVAILABLE AT THIS
POINT THERE'S SOME VERY
PROMISING DATA BUT IT'S PRETTY
LIMITED AND SO OUR
RECOMMENDATION WAS JUST -- TO
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT REPORT BACK
ON I'M WHAT ITS PLANS COULD BE
FOR EVALUATING THE SUCCESS THAT
PROGRAM ON A ONGOING BASIS THAT
WAY THE LEGISLATURE CAN ENSURE
THAT IT'S ACHIEVING THE INTENDED
OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
I SHOULD BE SHORT OF QUESTIONS
IS I NOTICED IN TERMS OF THE THE
STAFFING -- THAT YOU'VE INCLUDED
A RECRUITER POSITION -- WHICH I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT SEEMS LIKE
WITH ALL THE NEEDS THAT YOU HAVE.
OF THE EURO YOU REALLY NEED A
RECRUITER AS MUCH AS YOU DO.
OTHER STAFF IN SO -- I'M NOT
SURE WHY.
WITH WITH THE SUCCESS THAT
YOU'RE HAVING AN IS -- WAIT.
THE WAIT LIST.
RUMORS A WAIT LIST AT ALL LEVELS
THE FROM THE FUNCTION OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS MORE OF AN
ADMISSIONS COORDINATOR.
WHAT THEY DO IS ONCE THEIR
PARENTS EXPRESSED INTEREST AND
WE RUN THROUGH OUR LOTTERY
SYSTEM TO SELECT WHICH?
STUDENTS ARE TO BE ABLE TO
ATTEND THEY THEN ASSIST THE THE
PARENTS OF THE GUARDIANSOF THE
POTENTIAL STUDENT TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE ALL THE PAPERWORK ALL
THE REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION.
THEY NEED TO COMMAND SO IT'S
PRETTY IMPORTANT -- POSITIONS TO
HELP DO THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE INTAKE SO IT'S VERY MUCH AN
ADMINISTRATIVE POSITION AS
OPPOSED TO SOMEONE THAT'S GOING
OUT -- TO GO FIND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE INTEREST IN THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE AS YOU MENTIONED THE
PROGRAMS ARE.
ARE WAY OVER SUBSCRIBED YEAH.
AND THEN ON THE SECOND -- YOU
TALK ABOUT CERTIFICATES THAT THE
STUDENTSWOULD EARN COULD YOU
JUST QUICKLY.
DESCRIBE HOW HOW THAT SERVES TO
GET.
INTO A REAL CAREER OR A JOB
PLACEMENT FOR WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP RIGHT NOW WITH -- TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- CYPRESS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THEN LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE IN ORDER TO
DO -- CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS FOR
TRADES WILL ALSO WORK WITH --
TRADE UNIONS IN THE AREA TO TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE DEMAND IS FOR
EMPLOYMENT IN.
IN -- SEVERAL JOB FIELDS AND
THEN MANY OF THOSE JOB FEELS
REQUIRE WAR IT ENHANCES THE THE
MARKETABILITY OF THE CANDIDATE
IF THEY COME OUT OF THE PROGRAM
WITH A CERTIFICATE IN WHATEVER
CAREER FIELD THE GOING INTO.
OKAY [inaudible]
YES.
BUT I'M SURE WE FINISHED YES --
THE QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
CYPRUS IN LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE -- ARE.
ARE ANY PARTS THE PROGRAM GOING
TO BE OPERATED AT THE LOCATION
OR IS IT.
INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO COME
BELOW SELL NEEDLES CENTER FOR
FOR FORGET ALL MAKE SURE WE GET
WITH YOUR STAFF AND TO IMITATE
EXTEND AN INVITATION FOR YOU AND
I CAN VISIT THE OTHER SCHOOLS
BUT THE STUDENTS WILL LIVE AND
DO THEIR PHYSICAL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT LOS.
ALAMITOS WILL TRANSPORT THEM TO
THE SCHOOL CAMPUSES WHERE
THEY'LL ACTUALLY DO THE THE
CLASSROOM WORK WHICH HELPS US TO
BECAUSE THEN WE DON'T HAVE TO
SET ASIDE ADDITIONAL CLASSROOM
SPACE.
AT OUR BASE SO THAT'S PART OF
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE'VE DONE IN
THE SCHOOLS.
AND IF I COULD -- JUST ADDRESS
BRIEFLY THE LA OWES I THINK THE
ONLY A SUGGESTION OF DOING A
LONGITUDINAL STUDY. TO TRACK THE
EFFICACY THE PROGRAM IS GOOD WE
WOULD WELCOME THAT.
ON WHAT WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
INITIALLY AND WE CAN HAVE FOR
THE TALKS ON A BOAT -- WERE OPEN
TO TRACKING MAYBE FOR THE FIRST
YEAR HOW MANY THE PEOPLE TO
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM ACTUALLY
GET HIRED IN THE TRADES FOR
WHICH THEY TRAINED.
AND THEN A LONGITUDINAL STUDY
THAT GOES PERHAPS TEN YEARS OUT --
THAT TRACKS DID THEY STAY IN
THEIR CAREER FIELD TO THE GO
MOVE INTO A BETTER CAREER FIELD
OR SO SOME OF THE PROBLEM.
THE OTHER IDEA THAT THE LA --
HAD THAT I REALLY LIKE ALSO IS
TO ALSO.
YOU ATTRACT THE STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE FROM OUR REGULAR
CHALLENGE PROGRAMS BUT DON'T
GOING TO THE JOB CHALLENGE
PROGRAM.
AND SEE IF THE KIDS TO GO
THROUGH THE JOB CHALLENGE
PROGRAM HAVE GREATER SUCCESS IN
THEIR FIRST EN YEARS OF THE
CAREER THEN.
THE STUDENTS THAT MERELY GO
THROUGH THE HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY PROGRAM.
ON BECAUSE IN THAT CASE IS A
GOOD CONTROL TO SEE -- HOW WELL
THIS NEW PROGRAM IS WORKING?
I CAN -- CAM MOVE.
PLEASE COME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO I THINK I WOULD HAVE
THE OUT THERE IS THAT -- WHILE
THE LONGER TERM THE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT ACTUALLY REQUIRES
PROBABLY A BIT OF RESOURCES AND
SORT OF BEING STAFFED UP TO BE A
FIFTEEN THAT INFORMATION SO I
THINK IN THE NEAR TERM.
WEWOULD PRIORITIZE FOCUSING ON
WHAT JOBS FOLKS GET INTO.
IN TERMS OF THE TRACKING IN
TERMS OF THE TRACKING YEAH I
THINK LONG TERM WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT YOU KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE GO AND WHAT FEELS THEY
EXPAND INTO BUT IN THE NEAR TERM
WE'RE NOT REALLY RESOURCE TO DO
THAT.
OR SET UP TO DO THAT.
OKAY WHAT I WANT LONG DISCUSSION
BUT I I THINK THAT'S CRITICAL IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY IS
ENSURING THAT WHATEVER WE'RE
DOING.
ACTUALLY HAS SOME BENEFIT OVER
THE LONG TERM SO I WOULD BE
INTERESTED SOME POINT AND
UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO BE ABLE TO ADD
THAT KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY?
SO I I GET NOT FOR TODAY BUT NO
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE CLEAR THAT WE COULD
MAYBE WE WOULD MAKE MY NEED TO
COME BACK IN THE FUTURE.
SOMETHING OF THAT MAGNITUDE THAT
WOULD BE GOOD TO DO THE EXIT
YOUR EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY SO.
OF SALT ALFA MOVE THE OF ITEM
SEVENTY TWO ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVENTY TWO OF MOVES -- COULD
PROVE IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
BY.
LOCAL ENERGY DORADO HI SENATOR
NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
OKAY THE WORLD IN OPEN SEVENTY
THREE WE'RE GONNA HOLD OPEN HOLD
ON FOR FAMILY PLANNING THANK YOU
THANK YOU RENDON'S AS A THANK
YOU FOR SELF -- WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE GONNA JUMP TO ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH IS A SIMILAR
DEVELOPMENT CENTER.
ON ITEM -- SEVENTY FIVE IF THE
IF YOU COULD.
SPEAK TO THIS UP I I'M INCLINED
TO ACT ACTUALLY MOVED.
TO APPROVE THIS MATTER -- SO
WITH WITH BUDGET REPORTING
LANGUAGE ON THE STATUS OF THE
PROPER THE COUNTY MEETING GOALS
AND THE PROGRESS TO THE
COMMISSION THE SITE THAT'S WHAT
I'M INCLINED TO DO.
SO YOU'RE GONNA TELL ME WHY I'M
WRONG HEADED [inaudible]
THE UNITED.
NO NO -- THANK YOU -- JASON KIDD
HIM APARTMENT JOURNAL SERVICES I
OVERSEE OUR REAL ESTATE DIVISION --
YES OF THE PROPOSAL IS OF
SOMEONE STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S
SEEKING FUNDING TO MAINTAINING
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE ACRE
CAMPUS IN CINEMA FOR THREE YEARS --
AND THEN SUCCESSFULLY
DISPOSITION THE PROPERTY IN A
WAY THAT BENEFITS BOTH THE STATE
pAND SUPPORT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY --
THIS IS THE OLDEST OF THE DON'T
KNOW CENTERS IT WAS --
ORIGINALLY CONSTRUCTED IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE IN SERIES OF
WAVES -- AND THE FACILITIES BE
ON ITS USEFUL LIFE ULTIMATELY --
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN HERE IS THE
FUNDING WOULD ALLOW DDS TO
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE CAMPUS
AND -- SHUT DOWN -- HE REDUCTION
OF FROM THEIR THEIR CURRENT
LEVELS OF OPERATION THE LAST
PATIENT THE TO LEAVE THE SITE IN
DECEMBER -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN
HOWEVER THE FUNDING THE PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING FOR THE
CAUCUSES THAT THE COUNTY OF
CINEMA TO REZONE THE PROPERTY --
THAT IS SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL -- FOR
PROPOSAL LIKE THIS HOWEVER --
THE WAY THAT PROP THE PROPERTY
IS CURRENTLY ZONED REDUCE THE
VALUE CONSIDERABLY -- THE
FUNDING IS TO HELP THE COUNTY
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS -- IN TERMS
OF THE COST OF A THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE DIFF
THE AMOUNT OF MAINTENANCE MONEY
TO SAVE HOWEVER OVER THE
DURATION IS ABOUT FORTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS SO IT'S A GREAT
RETURN ON INVESTMENT TO TO FUND
THIS -- ULTIMATELY THIS IS --
THE RESULT OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE STATE THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS THE NUMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON INCLUDING CENTER DOTS AND
REQUIRE AN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY -- AND FINALLY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND CINEMA
HAVE ALSO -- RESOUNDINGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL -- THEY
PASSED A RESOLUTION APRIL FIFTH --
SHOWING THEIR SUPPORT AND
AUTHORIZING STAFF TO BEGIN WORK
ON THE PLANNING PROCESS AND HER
HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION LA YOU.
BUT A HUNG CHRISTINE SO WE HAVE
A FEW COMMENTS -- UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS HAS BEEN THE THE
RESULT OF QUITE AN EXTENSIVE
PROCESS -- BUT THERE ARE SOME
TWEAKS THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE THINK WOULD HELP IMPROVE
SOME LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THIS PROCESS I'M GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT'S
INVOLVED IN REALLY -- THAT THE
FACT IT IS A VERY LARGE PROPERTY
I'M SO THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE HAVE INCLUDE FIRST --
LIMITING FUNDING TO NINETEEN
TWENTY SO ON THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THREE YEARS
TO THIS WE WOULD RECOMMEND JUST
FINDING THE NINETEEN TWENTY
ABOUT HAVING TO COME BACK NEXT
YEAR.
A COUPLE REASONS FOR THIS ONE WE
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THAN THAT
OUT YOUR COSTS ARE GONNA BE THAT
WOULD GIVE THE UP THE
LEGISLATURE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REEVALUATE THOSE COSTS IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
AND WE ALSO THINK I'M JUST
HAVING THEM REPORT BACK AT THAT
TIME ABOUT THE STATUS OF THAT
PROJECT AND AND THE DISPOSITION
WOULD BE HELPFUL SO WE CAN
THAT'S A NICE CHECK AND SECONDS --
WE'RE RECOMMENDING HAVING THAT
THE FUNDING FOR CINEMA COUNTY BE
DONE ON A REIMBURSEMENT BASIS IN
PART BECAUSE THE DEAD STATE
DOESN'T USUALLY -- FUND THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY AND SO -- IT'S
IT'S DIFFICULT TO VERIFY WITH
CERTAINTY WHETHER THIS IS
EXACTLY RIGHT FUNDING AMOUNTS WE
THINK OF REIMBURSEMENT BASIS
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE -- THIRD
WERE SUGGESTING -- AN AMENDMENT
TO THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
THAT COULD FURTHER SPECIFY THE
LEGISLATURE'S GOALS FOR THE
PROPERTY SO CURRENTLY SO --
ALONG WITH THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
THERE'S TRAILER BILL AND THAT'S
PROPOSED WHICH WOULD BASICALLY
EXEMPT THIS PROPERTY FROM THE
TRADITIONAL SURPLUS PROPERTY
PROCESS WHICH WHICH HAS SORT OF
A LOADING ORDER FOR THINGS YOU
KNOW WAYS AT FIRST THAT PROPERTY
IS MADE AVAILABLE.
TO YOU KNOW WHEN USE THAN THE
NEXT AND THE NEXT ON THE TO
CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE PROCESS
I'M CERTAINLY THERE'S A
RATIONALE FOR USING AN ALTERNATE
PROCESS IN THIS IN THIS CASE --
BUT THE LANGUAGE IS PRETTY BROAD
AND IT GIVES QUITE A BIT OF
AUTHORITY TO THE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTOR -- AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAD MORE
SPECIFIC GOALS FOR THE PROPERTY
FOR EXAMPLE RELATED TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR THE THIS --
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY IT COULD FURTHER
SPECIFY THOSE -- JUST TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE -- DIRECTION IF
IT'S INTERESTED IN DOING.
AND THEN -- WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING I MIGHT FIND A
TRAILER BILL.
LOOK LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT -- ONE
POSSIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE IS TO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT I HAD TO
DO A DEAL BE SEATED LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE NOTIFICATION
PRIOR TO ENTERING INTO A LONG
TERM LEASE OR THE SALE.
ON THAT WOULD GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE JUST A CHECK AND SO
I COULD SEE COULD.
EVALUATE WHETHER.
IT'S COMFORTABLE WITH THE
PROPOSED APPROACH FOR THE SOUTH.
AND THEN THE FINAL COMMENT WE
HAD IS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S
COMFORTABLE WITH SETTING
POTENTIALLY SETTING A PRECEDENT
ON FOR THIS PROCESS FOR THIS
PROPERTY SO THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
UNUSUAL.
PROCESS -- IT'S ALSO AN UNUSUAL
SET AMOUNT OF MONEY AND AND SOME
OF THE THINGS ARE FINDING OUR
LAW AND USUAL -- AND SO --
CERTAINLY THERE ARE SOME UNIQUE
ASPECTS OF THIS PROPERTY IT'S
VERY LARGE IT HAS SOME VERY OLD.
BUILDINGS THAT HAS SOME HIS --
SOME WILDLIFE ISSUES AND AND
ALSO THE COMMUNITY THAT WAS
AFFECTED BY THE WILDFIRES.
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT -- AND
ALL THESE DIFFERENT FACTORS BUT
CERTAINLY OTHER COMMUNITIES
COULD ALSO -- COULD ALSO ARGUE
THAT THEIR UNIQUE THINGS AND SO
REALLY TO THEIR COMMUNITY SO WE
JUST WANTED TO FIND OUT FOR HE
LEGISLATURE'S WHILE.
ON BECAUSE BECAUSE THIS COULD BE
SOMETHING OTHER COMMUNITIES ASK.
FOR DID YOU WANT.
TO RESPOND TO YOU GUYS ARE GOOD
[inaudible]
BECAUSE I MEAN I YEAH I THINK I
CAN JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
SOME IS ALTERNATELY -- I THINK
THE REPORTING LANGUAGE AS
MENTIONED -- IS IS A HELP IN
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS
REGULAR REPORTING ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THE SPENDING OF FUNDS -- I
THINK ALSO -- TO IS RELATED TO
ME.
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE BETTER
THANK YOU -- THE IN TERMS OF
THIS THE THE PARITY WITH THE
STATE'S EXISTING SURPLUS
PROPERTY PROCESS -- YES THERE'S
A THERE'S SOMETHING A LOADING
ORDER EXISTING GOVERNMENT CODE
HOWEVER THE SAME -- OBJECTIVES
ARE LISTED IN THE TRAILER BILL --
MUST HAVE THIS PROPERTY IS GONNA
BE LARGELY SUBJECT TO THE ZONING
PROCESS AND SO THE STATE WILL BE
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING HOUSING A
COMMERCIAL VIABILITY IN USE --
AND SO THOSE THINGS WILL STILL
BE ADDRESSED THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS THERE'S ALSO A
PREFERENCE FOR A HOUSING FOR
THOSE.
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AS WELL --
THERE WILL ALSO -- IN WHEN THE
STATE TRADITIONALLY DISPOSE OF
PROPERTY THE EXISTING AUTHORITY
GIVEN TO THE DIRECTOR IS
ACTUALLY ALSO QUITE BROAD -- TO
SOMETHING PROPOSED BY THE LA
WOULD BE -- DEVIATIONS IN THE
NORMAL WAY WHICH THE PROPERTIES --
DISPOSED OF THANK YOU.
OKAY.
I WOULD WITH ANY THAT IS A QUICK
QUESTION ABOUT THE THE ONE YEAR
VERSUS THREE YEAR.
ISSUE SO PARTLY.
IT'S BECAUSE OF OF CITING KNOWN
SO THE WAY THE COSTS WERE
GENERATED WERE OF BECAUSE GOOD
WITH THE ONE YEAR -- IT IT WOULD
BE -- OUR PREFERENCE AGO FOR THE
THE THREE YEARS ULTIMATELY -- IT
ALLOWS FOR GREATER FLEXIBILITY --
IN DISPOSITION THE CAMPUS --
MAINTAINING THE CAMPUS AS WELL
IT ALSO SUCH A CLEAR MESSAGE TO
THE COUNTY AND LOCALES AT ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE OKAY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA NOTICEABLE PULLS THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE I'M
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE LAMBING
COALITION WHICH IS A BROAD
COALITION MORE THAN TWENTY
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS.
REPRESENTING ADVOCATING FOR THE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS DRUG CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE SERVED AND SUPPORTED AS
ENTITLED UNDER THE LANHAM ACT --
IN THE CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER AS WE'VE HEARD MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED YEARS HAS BEEN PART
OF THE DDS SYSTEM.
AND WE AT THE ARE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATE FOR THE CLOSURE OF
INSTITUTIONS ABOUT LITTLE
CENTERS **** THE CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
AND WE'RE HAPPY THAT THAT
PROCESS IS HAPPY NOT JUST -- FOR
SNOW MOTHERS TO MORE -- ONE IN
COSTA MESA ONE PORTERFIELD AND
THOSE ARE ALSO SLATED TO BE
CLOSED IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
FOR YEARS HOWEVER OUR COMMUNITY
HAS ADVOCATED THAT WHEN THESE
ASSETS OR WHEN WE CLOSE THESE
INSTITUTIONS IN WHICH WE HAVE
DONE FOR SEVERAL OTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
THAT THAT ACID SHOULD CONTINUE
TO SERVE PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES I
DON'T MEAN THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO HAVE SERVICES ON THE
SITE ITSELF THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES IN HISTORY AND DRAMA.
AND ALSO IN TRAUMA ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT -- ALL WE ARE SAYING
IS THAT REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE ASSETS SHOULD BE USED TO
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPED TO
DISABILITIES OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE EXACTLY THIS.
WE HAS ALSO DONE SOMETHING IN A
IN COSTA MESA WITH PART OF THAT
PROPERTY -- SIMILAR TO AND WHAT
THE CONVERSATIONS THIS COMMITTEE
IS HAD PREVIOUSLY NOW AT TODAY
IS ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT'S SO MUCH MORE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES WHO -- FACE THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT OF WHEN IT COMES
TO HUG VOUCHERS.
DIFFICULTY AND DISCRIMINATION OF
ANY COMMUNITY PEOPLE
DISABILITIES.
SO AS A RESULT THE LAN
RECOLLECTION HAS PROPOSED THAT
REVENUE ASSOCIATE WITH THE
CLOSURE OF THESE ASSETS AND
REMINISCES WITH THE DISPOSITION
WHETHER IT'S A SALE OR LEASE.
SHOULD BE USED TO FUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOP THE DISABILITIES.
IT'S BEEN A PART BUDGET PROPOSAL
LAST YEAR A BILL LAST YEAR AND
ALSO A BILL THIS YEAR TO DO
EXACTLY THAT -- WE HAVE BEEN
AVERAGING THAT FOR THE FOR YEARS
AND WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT
THAT IS NOT INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
IF THE GS WHICH IS TO SPEND
MONEY ON A WARM SHUT DOWN AND
ALSO GIVE MONEY TO THE COUNTY --
TO DEVELOP A PLAN SO BE IT
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE STATE'S
CHOICE TO DO SO HOWEVER WHEN THE
PROPERTY HAS DISPOSITION WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT IN THE ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THAT'LL BE USED TO
RECOUP COSTS ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE WARM SHUT DOWN WE
BELIEVE THAT ANYTHING REVENUE
ASSOCIATE WITH THE DISPOSSESSED
DISPOSITION OF THIS PROPERTY
SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE USED TO
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS.
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
PROPOSALS TO BE USE THAT REVENUE
PUT INTO A SPECIAL FUND THAT CAN
BE USED SIMILAR TO OTHER HOUSING
FUNDS.
AND THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY IS READY TO
GO ON THIS THE A WANT THIS FUND
THEY WANT MONEY BE PUT INTO IT
WHATEVER MECHANISM IS AVAILABLE
AND THIS IS A REVENUE STREAM TO
BE PUT INTO THAT FUND. TO ALLOW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO HAPPEN
FOR PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPS IS PLEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS CARL LUNDEN I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING.
THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVOLVE
DISABILITIES.
LARSON ONE ECHO THE CONCERNS
pRAISED BY JORDAN LINDSEY.
OF THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
COLLABORATIVE I WANT TO MAKE A
JUST A COUPLE OF THE STATEMENTS.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS
LOOKED AT THESE CLOSURES OF
FINAL CLOSURES OF THESE
PROPERTIES.
AN ESTIMATED THAT THERE'S A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS.
THAT'S GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
GENERAL FUND AS A RESULT OF
THESE CLOSURES WHY BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE TODAY OR
THAT LIVE THERE RECENTLY ARE NO
LONGER GOING TO BE THERE AND NO
LONGER SERVED.
IN A STATE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
THAT MONEY GO SOMEWHERE.
THE COMMUNITY MEANWHILE THE FLIP
SIDE IN THIS IS A BUDGET SUB
THREE ITEMS APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULTY IN EXPRESSING THIS TO
YOU.
BUT THE COMMUNITY IS BEING
STIFFED AGAIN LARGELY IN THE
STATE BUDGET.
AND WE'VE HAD A HISTORY IN THE
STATE NOW OF ONLY TWO RATE
INCREASES FOR THE PROGRAMS OF
SUPPORT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
SO WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AS JORDAN
CORRECTLY NOTES AS A HISTORY IN
THE STATE.
OF CLOSURE OF THESE TREMENDOUS
ASSETS.
AND THE PROPERTIES BEING GIVEN
AWAY AND THE OPERATING DOLLARS
LEAVING THE SYSTEM AND NOT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES.
WE THINK IT'S A VERY SOON SEVERE
PROBLEM WE HAVE ONE LAST CHANCE.
TO GET THIS RIGHT THESE OF THE
FINAL THREE PROPERTIES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL HAVE A DISPOSITION IN THIS
AREA.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO URGE A PLAN
THAT INVOLVES COMMUNITY AND
DOESN'T RIGHT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO REASON.
THESE ASSETS SHOULD BE STRIPPED
FROM THE COMMUNITY THE OPERATING
DOLLARS TAKEN AWAY WITH NO
BENEFIT TO THE COMMUNITY WE
WOULD URGE YOU.
TO KEEP THIS OPEN TO HAVE A
FULLER DISCUSSION INVOLVING SUB.
THREE AND OTHER LEADERSHIP AND
AND LOOK TO YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AIRING CARUTHERS.
RECORD THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETY THE BEST
THING TO DO FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPING
DISABILITIES WAS TO TAKE AWAY
AND PUT HIM INTO A PLACE LIKE A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AN
INSTITUTION WHERE.
THAT'S WHERE THEY WOULD STAY IN%
AND LORD IN CARE WAS PROVIDED TO
THEM -- BY THE STATE.
WE KNOW BETTER NOW AND WE
APPRECIATE APPLAUD THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SENATE'S
DIRECTION IN CLOSING DOWN THESE.
VESTIGES OF WHAT ONCE WAS THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT THE BEST WAY
TO DO IT NOW TAKE CARE PEOPLE IS
IN THE COMMUNITY -- WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE MOVING PEOPLE TOWARD THE
COMMUNITY THE CHALLENGES THAT
WHEN PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT LIVING ON
THEIR OWN.
A 70% OF REGIONAL CENTER CLIENTS
ARE LIVING WITH THEIR FAMILIES --
THAT FAMILIES ARE QUICKLY AGING
OF THIS.
ISSUE BRINGS UP AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT WHERE PEOPLE LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY AND STATE
COUNCIL ASK YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT AS YOU CONSIDER
THE DISPOSITION OF THIS PROPERTY
THANK YOU.
TURNING NOT IN TURN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CINEMA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS BEEN AT THE
TABLE -- WITH THEIR IT
LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION DDS DDS
FOR FOUR YEARS ON THIS TOPIC.
THE HOME WAS CLOSED OUT BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MADE A
DECISION THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
FIND CONGREGATE LIVING.
ANYMORE AND THE STATE IS CLOSING
THE CENTERS AS ARESULT OF A
FEDERAL DECISION FROM FOUR YEARS
AGO.
SO THAT IS THE REASON HOMELESS
CLOSING THE COUNTY HAS WORKED
TOGETHER WITH THE COALITION
ACTUALLY REPRESENTED THE PARENT
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WHICH IN
TURN IS AN ADVOCACY GROUP FOR
THE RESIDENTS OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER AND THEY'VE
ALL BEEN AT THE TABLE TOGETHER
FOR FOUR YEARS.
FIRST THE FOCUS IS ONE WAS ON
THE RESIDENTS.
THEN I WAS ON THE EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE IS THE LARGEST EMPLOYER
IN THE CINEMA VALLEY AND NOW
WE'RE ON THE DISPOSITION OF THE
PROPERTY THE STATUS SPENT TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DEVELOPING HOMES FOR THE
RESIDENTS USED TO LIVE THERE.
THAT ARE NOW OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE COUNTY HAS
BEEN SUPPORTIVE EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY WHAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY.
IS THE DISPOSITION OF THE
PROPERTY I CAN ASSURE YOU THIS
IS A TWO LANE ROAD.
AND ON A THOUSAND ACRES SO IT'S
NOT LIKE THE COSTA MESA PROPERTY
WHICH IS INSIDE OF THE CITY
LIMIT AND HAS EXISTING ZONING.
THIS IS A HUGE PIECE OF PROPERTY
THAT BACKS UP TO THE WILD IN
URBAN INTERFACE TWENTY SOMETHING
BUILDINGS I BELIEVE BURN IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO IN THE BACK
OF THE PROPERTY PROBABLY
RIGHTFULLY NEEDS TO REMAIN OPEN
SPACE THERE'S A CORE.
I CENTER OF THE CAMPUS IS IT'S
REFERRED TO THAT -- THIS THE
CITY IS WITH THE COUNTY IS GOING
TO WORK WITH I DID YES ON THE
DEVELOP THE APPROPRIATE ZONING
SO THAT WHEN DID ES TURNS
AROUND TO SELL IT TO PRIVATE.
INTERESTS THEY CAN EXTRACT THE
HIGHEST PRICE POSSIBLE WHAT TO
DO WITH THAT MONEY IS WHAT THE
STATE IS GOING TO DO WITH THAT
MONEY BUT THIS WILL GET YOU TO
SOME SORT OF DISPENSATION WITH
THE JAZZ.
THAT THE COUNTY CAN LIVE WITH
AND THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO PUT
HOUSING ARE AND I KNOW I HEARD
THE HOMELESS AND HOUSING
DISCUSSION FIRST. FOR THE COUNTY
IS AWARE OF THAT THE THREE YEARS
IS PROBABLY WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO MAKE SURE THERE'S ROBUST
LOCAL INPUT AND I CAN PROMISE
YOU.
THERE HAVE BEEN MEETINGS UPON
MEETINGS UPON MEETINGS THAT
SENATOR DODD SENATOR REQUIRE.
THE I. WORKER OF ALL THE TIME
AND THIS IS AN ACTIVE ENGAGED SO
I'M GONNA MAKE.
YOU PROBABLY GONNA LIKE UNLESS
IF WE GOT OUT.
YEAH SO -- AND I'VE SPENT TIME
TALKING TO SENATOR DODD SAID I'M
REQUIRE ABOUT THIS MYSELF SO --
AND I HEAR THE CONCERNS.
THE BUT I'M GONNA MOVE THOUGH TO
PROVE IT IS REQUESTED WITH
BUDGET BILL REPORTING LANGUAGE
ON THE STATUS OF THE PROPERTY
THE COUNTY MEETING -- ITS GOALS
AND THE PROGRESS DISK THE
COMMISSION THE SITE THAT MOTION.
SENATOR OTHER FIVE FENDER
NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE INCLUDE ROOM
TAKE UP SOME OF THE OTHER
MATTERS [inaudible]
YES.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON SOME. TO
ISSUE SEVENTY EIGHT SUBSEQUENT
INJURY BENEFIT TRUST FUND.
AND AGAIN JUST THERE -- REMINDER
THAT.
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING.
OF THIS TODAY BUT WILL BE
HOLDING OPEN [inaudible]
THE ISSUE.
THE MANAGER MY NAME IS GREG
EDWARDS I'M.
THE CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS.
THE V. SEVEN WITHIN -- THREE
BENEFIT TRUST FUND IS A FUND.
THAT SUPPORTS BENEFIT PAYMENTS
TO WORKERS WHO HAVE -- AN
INITIAL INDUSTRIAL INJURY AND
THEN THE ONE OR MORE SUBSEQUENT
INJURIES RESULTING IN AT LEAST.
70% OF DISABILITY -- TO TO THE
PERSON -- THIS PROPOSAL WAS HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY -- BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEEN A TREMENDOUS SPIKE
BOTH IN THE NUMBER OF CASES AND
THE COST IMPACT. TO THIS FUND.
IT EXTENDS BEYOND OF ABILITY OF
OF CURRENT STAFF TO ADMINISTER --
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU --
REQUESTS FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF --
WHICH WILL TAPER DOWN OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS MAINLY TO HANDLE
THE CASELOAD MAINLY TO DO WITH
THE STATE'S DUE DILIGENCE -- TO
INSURE THAT THE BENEFITS PAID
OUT BENEFITS THAT -- OR CHARGE
TO EVERY EMPLOYER IN CALIFORNIA --
EVERY SCHOOL EVERY MUNICIPALITY
EVERY LAW ABIDING EMPLOYER --
PEAS OF THESE BENEFITS AND SO --
IT IS IN THE INTEREST OF THE
STATE THAT WE INSURE THAT -- WE
FEEL OUR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY AND THEN THESE
RESOURCES ARE REQUESTED A TO AN
ABLE US TO DO THAT.
CLARIFY HERE WHAT WOULD IT IS
THE REQUEST.
IS YOUR HOME IN A POSITION.
THE REQUESTED INITIALLY. FOR
THIRTY POSITIONS IN FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY OF FISCAL YEAR
THAT WILL TAPER DOWN -- TO ABOUT --
CARILLO. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN HERE
FOURTEEN POSITIONS TOTAL. SIX OF
THOSE WILL BE CASE WORKERS FOUR
OF THOSE WILL BE ATTORNEYS OF
THE REMAINING FOUR OR A LEGAL
SECRETARIES AND CLERICAL STAFF
TO HELP WITH THE PROCESS THE
PAPERWORK.
OKAY SO THIRTY POSITIONS.
WHICH WOULD THEN TAPERED OF
FOURTEEN IS THE BACK LOAD.
CORRECT.
BACKLOG I'M SORRY.
CURRENTLY THE CASELOAD PER CASE
WORKER IS A ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
PER -- THESE RACE RESOURCES
WOULD BRING THAT CASE SLOWED
DOWN INTO THE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY RANGE.
BASED ON THE CASELOAD WE HAVE
TODAY WHICH IS NOT STATIC WE ARE
SEEING MORE CASES COME IN EVERY
MONTH SO WITH THE WHOLE THE
ASPIRATION IN THE PROPOSAL IS.
IS THAT WE WILL SEE A TAPERING
DOWN OF THAT -- SHOULD THAT NOT
TAKE PLACE WE WILL HAVE TO
REVISIT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR FINANCE.
HI MARSHA MINUTES APARTMENT A
FINANCE ON JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A
FEW THINGS THAT MISTER EDWARDS
AND HAD PRESENTED THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PROPOSAL IS TO RIGHT SIZE
THE UNIT I'M BASED ON THEIR
EXISTING WORKLOAD HAS YET
POINTED OUT THEY HAVE ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND OPEN CASES WITH NINE
STAFF MANAGING.
A THOUSAND CASES WHICH IS --
IT'S DIFFICULT RIGHT I MEAN.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW WE I THE THE
STAFF COMMENTS NOTED THAT IT IS
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE BUT
WE THINK OF IT AS A WE SEE IT AS
ASTRATEGIC INVESTMENT AT LEAST
IN THE AND IN THE FRONT END.
TO ADDRESS THE THE BACKLOG OF
CASES -- AND INSURE THAT WERE
THOROUGHLY VETTING OUT THE
APPLICATIONS AND THEN WERE OF
COURSE ASSUMING THAT -- THE
WORKLOAD WOULD DECREASE IN -- IN
THE OUT YEARS AND THERE'S A
CORRESPONDING REDUCTION AND AND
IN IN SERVICES -- BASED ON THAT
SO [inaudible]
STERLING.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEHAMA THE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE NO
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSAL HAS -- PRESENTED I
THINK THE ONE THING WE WOULD
POINT OUT THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE AGENDA IS THAT EARLIER ON
THERE WAS A ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE CHANGES TO
THE PROGRAM ITSELF ON THE SORT
OF THE THE THE OTHER SIDE --
THAT WAS DESIGNED OR AT LEAST AS
I UNDERSTAND IT -- TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE WORKLOAD -- THIS
PROPOSAL NOW WOULD WOULD --
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO WORK
ON THAT WORK WELL BUT I THINK
THAT THE BIG OPEN QUESTION IS IF
THE TRAJECTORY.
OF THESE CASES CONTINUES TO
INCREASE -- IT WE COULD BE HERE
AGAIN IN THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
RECONSIDERING THAT THAT WORKLOAD.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY HEARING NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE IT WILL EVEN
THIS OPEN.
OKAY WE'RE GOING.
TO SEVENTY NINE OKAY ITEM
SEVENTY NINE REGARDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING FOR THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE THIS A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WILL
HARMONIZE TWO SEPARATE BILLS A
PAST -- IN RECENT YEARS -- AT A.
B. NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
WHICH WAS PASSED.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THEM
UNFORTUNATELY.
THESE THESE BILLS CREATED TWO
SEPARATE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
TO THE SAME COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
VIS CHANGES WILL HELP OUR
HARMONIZE THAT AND THEN FOR FEEL --
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF BOTH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OF HIS FINANCE LOW ALEJO'S.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RENEE BY
ARTEMISIA YOU CALIFORNIA WE
SPONSORED AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
WHICH IMPLEMENTED OF THIS
REQUIREMENT AND WE SUPPORT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY.
ANYTHING YOU WANT.
IT'S A QUESTIONS OF ANYONE.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOOD.
WE'LL LIKE BEING GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- IT WILL BE DONE TO ISSUE.
EIGHTY REGARDING THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURERS SPECIAL ACCOUNT.
SO I WILL -- BRIEFLY IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME -- JUST TO ECHO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE IN
OF THE AGENDA.
I BELIEVE WE TESTIFIED ON THIS
ISSUE A ONE THE EXECUTIVE COURT
ORDER TO TRANSFER THREE POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
UNPAID WAY TRYING TO THE GARMENT
RESTITUTION FUND.
HAS BEEN EXECUTED.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF CLOSING
THOSE CASES AND APPEARING TO
ISSUE CHECKS -- AS WE SPEAK --
OF THAT THE TRANSFER OF FROM THE
PAID WHICH FUND -- TAKES THE
OUTSTANDING CLAIM AMOUNT DOWN
FROM ABOUT ELEVEN POINT -- TWO
UNTIL -- APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
CLAIMS WE ARE WATCHING THE CLOCK
A VERY -- CAREFULLY WE HAVE A
CUT OFF THAT WE HAVE TO ABIDE BY
IN IN ORDER TO CLOSE OUR BOOKS
ON TIME THIS YEAR WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S BUT WE WE
ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO MAKE ONE MORE TRANSFER WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DOLLAR VALUE
OF THAT TRANSFER WILL BE YET --
BUT I DO NOT IN ANYWAY WANT TO
IMPLY.
THAT THAT TRANSFER WILL RESOLVE
ALL THE OUTSTANDING CLAIMS
BECAUSE IT WILL -- SO DOES THAT
PUT INTO JEOPARDY THE CLAIMS
MADE BY THE WORKERS THE NOT AT
ALL NOT AT ALL UNFORTUNATELY IT
SHOWS.
UP MEANS THAT THAT THOSE WORKERS
WHO ARE OLD THOSE WE JUST HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO WAIT UNTIL WE
COME UP WITH A PERMANENT
SOLUTION THE B. C. P. THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR WAS ONLY. FOR A
ONE TIME TRANSFER -- AT THE TIME
THAT SEEMED TO BE UPROOTED
DECISION BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN AN
UPTICK IN CLAIMS THAT WAS --
UNANTICIPATED -- AND WITH NO
CONTEXT THE HISTORY SO WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHETHER WE WERE LOOKING AT
AN ABERRATION OR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW PATTERN
OVER THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS OR
SO WHAT.
WAS AT THE TIME OF FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG IN
CLAIMS CHURNED INTO AN ELEVEN
PLUS MILLION
DOLLARS A BACKLOG AND CLEAN IN
ONE YEAR SO IT'S EVIDENT EVEN
THOUGH WE ONLY HAVE TWO YEARS IN
WHAT APPEARS TO BE OUR NEW
REALITY.
IT'S EVIDENT THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE SOME LONG TERM PERMANENT
ACTION WE WILL BE WORKING WITH
THE LABOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND THE ADMINISTRATION --
TO DETERMINE -- THE BEST AND
MOST APPROPRIATE WAY TO TO MOVE
FORWARD OKAY.
OFFICE OF FINANCE -- WE JUST
WANTED -- ECHO THAT -- WE HAVE
FIVE PROCESS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO TRANSFER THREE POINT NINE
FIVE MILLION AND OF COURSE WERE
WERE MONITORING CLOSELY TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW -- WE COULD --
TRANSFER IN ANOTHER AS MUCH AS
WE CAN TO TO SUPPORT SOME OF THE
EXISTING CLAIMS AND WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH HE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO ASSESS
AND EVALUATE THE SUSTAINABILITY
OF UP TO FIND.
I MEAN IT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THERE'S GOTTA BE A WAY TO PAY
THIS OFF I MEAN WHY SHOULD THE
PEOPLE WHO.
GOT [inaudible]
GET.
IN THE FIRST PLACE UP TO WAIT SO
LONG.
AND AND WE NEED TO GET THAT
DOLLAR FIGURE IS THAT WOULD WE
DON'T HAVE A DOLLAR WE DO HAVE A
FUND IS INSOLVENT.
AND SO WHAT THE SEA CHANGE WAS
CREATED BY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
TWO YEARS AGO -- IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET ACTIVE ACTUALLY
RAISED THE DAMAGES -- AND
INCREASE THE AWARDS THAT CLAIM
IT'S COULD RECEIVE AND SO WHAT
WAS IN RETROSPECT WITH THE VALUE
OF HINDSIGHT NOT ANTICIPATED AT
THAT TIME IS OF THE BURDEN THAT
WOULD PUT ON THE FEE STRUCTURE
WHICH HASN'T BEEN REVISED IN
DECADES SO.
THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS TO BE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT AS A
PRACTICE OF SOLUTIONS GOING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CINDY
DO WE I AM A MEMBER OF A D. W.
C. I. CAM TO THE STATE ON THE
BUTTON BELOW I HAVE A DOMESTIC.
FOR AS A DOMESTIC WORKER IT WAS
LABOR TRAFFICKING SITUATION WHEN
I SKIP IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
I BEGIN TO GO MORE CAR SO SO WE
MACHINE OPERATOR I'M DOING
SINGLE NEITHER AN OVERLOOKED.
I MADE THOUSAND OF PRESSES.
UP BEING INDONESIAN WITH LIMITED
LANGUAGE SKILL CAN MEAN A JOB
THAT PAID ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE FOUR FIFTY FIVE HOURS A
WEEK.
IN THIS COMPANY.
PAY ME BY THE THROAT WHICH
DOESN'T MEAN IT WITH.
MINIMUM WAGE MY EMPLOYER TO MAKE
UP FOR ME THE THREAT PRICES.
THE COMPANY ALL DIDN'T CLOSE THE
DOOR FROM INSIDE [inaudible] TO
BRING.
MISSION INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A PERMIT TO
OPERATE.
IN THE SUMMERTIME TO FACTORY
BECOME VERY HOT BECAUSE THERE IS
NO WINDOW AND THE ONLY FRIEND IN.
THE DUST AROUND.
THE WORKER DIDN'T GET PRESS
MUSCLE WORKERS MIGHT ON
CHRISTMAS FROM THE SCRAP FABRIC.
AND NOT AND I WORE.
IN THIS COMPANY FOR ALMOST TWO
YEARS IN THE NEXT.
THE COMPANY PAY ME THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY A WEEK BUT AFTER SIX
MONTHS I WASN'T BAY FOR THREE
WEEKS.
I I STILL OWED.
PLEASE HELP US TO ELIMINATE
THROWN AWAY PLEASE.
GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD FUND THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE OF THE OUT OF
THIS UP ALL THOSE. FOR YOU NON
THE LESS CONVINCING COMICAL
TODAY THAT'S GET THAT OF A
HYUNDAI LEVINE WHO THIS ENORMOUS
MONEY BUT IT COULD ALSO.
IT'S THE LOCAL THOUGHT IT UP ON
MY LIVING TO SEE IF THE ONIONS.
BUT BY THE CENTRAL THAT THE OF A
HOLLOW IT IS THE LOCAL STUDENTS.
BETTER GET ALTHOUGH MOST BARGAIN
WHEN SOMEBODY WHO STOLE.
THE MAJORITY OTHER LAW SCHOOLS
TO DENTAL SCHOOL MORE YOU'LL.
ABOUT HOW MOST BOTTOM BOTTOM WE
MUST ALSO LOBBYIST INFORMATICA
SO SAYS THE BELLY ALSO.
I'M WE JUST ALREADY BECAUSE CON
MY LESS GOING TO SEE HONEST ON
BUT THE SCHOOL GOT A CHANCE.
BY YOUR SOULS USED IN ARE YOU
WHAT THE AMERICANS DIDN'T EVEN
THE LESSEE ON IF THAT'S PROBABLY
GOT SO DON'T BELIEVE IT'LL BUT
ON A SORE THROAT.
LET'S JUST MOVE JUST ABOUT HOW
LOTUS GILLIS BOTTOM FOR PS ON A
FOR THE MOST AMOUNT OF THIS
CONSULS FOR THE MOST EIGHTY
THOSE THE MONUMENTAL REPEATED
THE WALLS OF THE MONTH.
LET ME TAKE A LOOK AT THE ARM.
WHEN SOMEONE ELSE FIVE OF US YET
MAYBE CALL THE MOST AVAILABLE
YET THAT HE WOULD CHECK CAN?
SOLVE THIS.
MY FATHER OF ON THE ME THE
MIDDLE WE CAN ALSO SOMEONE MUST
BE YES [inaudible] ELEVEN JUST
LET ME GO OUT ON THE WITH THIS
IF YOU DON'T SEND ALL THE BIRTH
OF A HOLD OF THE LOCAL STUDENT.
ALISON BEAT UP FOR YOU. FOR
THOSE THAT ARE COMING WHO WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT US EMAIL SOME
CONCEPT BUT I'VE YOU GIVE.
THE SOLO ON A MOBILE SIMPLE
CINCUENTA ADDRESS IN BOTH
[inaudible]
ALSO MAMA. ONE OF THE NAY U.
CLOSE ENOUGH FOR THEM ALSO GOT
OTHER LONG THICK.
DON'T GET OKAY ALTHOUGH LESS FUN
BECAUSE BY GETTING SOMEBODY WHO
STOLE EVEN THOUGH IS AND I WAS
GONNA TRANSLATE DO YOU NEED ME.
TO MAYBE IF YOU HAVE LIKE A
THREE HOUR SET YES THEY CAN OF
EVERY PLEASE YEAH SO -- HERE
EVERYONE ELSE YEAH SO MY NAME IS
MARIA COULD GET ALL SIGNED ONE
OF THE FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
GARMENT WORKERS IN LOS ANGELES
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN GOVERNMENT
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER -- THERE ARE A LOT
OF TERRIBLE CONDITIONS WITHIN
THE FACTORIES LAKE ROAD IN SNOW
EXITS WE DON'T GET BREAKS
THERE'S NO FIRST AID -- AND WE
ALSO SUFFER FROM REPETITIVE
MOVEMENT INJURIES IN HER CASE
SHE WORKED AT A FACTORY FOR
THREE YEARS AT ONE POINT SHE
DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY CHECKS FOR
THREE WEEKS -- SHE APPROACHED
HER BOSS AND THE BOSS SAID I'M
NOT GIVING YOU ANY MORE MONEY
YOU'RE TRYING TO ROB ME -- SHE
CAME OUT OF THE OFFICE CRYING IN
AND WENT DIRECTLY TO THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER TO SEEK SUPPORT --
IT'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY TO LIVE
OFF OF TO ONLY BE MAKING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
A WEEK -- WE HAVE CHILDREN I
CURRENTLY HAVE A CASE IN PROCESS
I'M NOT SURE WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WITH THAT CASE BUT I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT -- OTHER GARMENT WORKERS
WHO ARE ON THE WAIT LIST AND I
AM VERY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNMENT -- HELPING GARMENT
WORKERS TO ELIMINATE THIS --
WEIGHTLESS IN THE STATE FUND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN I STARTED AS A FATHER'S ME
NUMBER IS WITH THE LOCAL MENTAL?
SO YOU MEMBER OVER CENTRAL TO
COVER HER DAUGHTER'S ACOSTA
WATER.
BINGO THE ASSOCIATE THE ANNUAL
SUMMER HUMBER MICHAEL STORE.
SO CHECK YOUR BRANCH OF LAURA.
THE WHOLE ROOM.
ROPER.
HE OF THE OLD GUYS SO. FOUR OKAY
IN THE PHARMACY KERN.
THE ONE DAY YOUR BUT OUR HURRY.
YEAH THEIR OWN LAWS AND AS THE
OTHER IS THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
EVEN GOING ALL.
MAYBE HERE OKAY A PART PRO KNOWS
A VIA.
ON THE NATIONAL PARK IN THE
FARGO WHEN WE BOOK IT THROUGH.
YOU IF YOU AYE GO AHEAD BUT
BROWN KNOWS THE WHOLE K. COME
YET ALMOST AS A CHICKEN BACON
WILL BE AT A LOSS IT WILL BE
MANDATORY OKAY.
IT OF A LIST OF THE MENTAL.
HE COMO NORMAL THEY WILL BE IN
THE MAIL I AM IT MAY THIS BE THE
OTHER THING OF OUR WHOLE.
HE BORDERS ARE WHAT I HAVE BEEN
GOAL GRASS OR YEAH.
AND YOUR COMMISSION MODEL NUMBER
ONE THEY LOVE ME CAN SAY.
END PROCESS OF ARMENIA.
NO SE SI [inaudible]
GRASSO MARA.
BY ENTERING OUR REFORM BOAST BUT
BY [inaudible]
HE UNDER A SPREAD AROUND THE
INGE LIS.
THEY THERE'S FOR FOR WATER.
ARE YOU ARE MOST [inaudible]
FOUR K..
A LOCAL STORE AND ALMOST BURKE
I'M BEING SO FOR THE MOST MONTH
BUT I POSE.
YOUR PAPERWORK ALL THAT TOGETHER
WHAT I I WILL REALLY BE A SON.
IS BAY I LEFT ALL MY SCHOOL GOT
AYE CHAU MOMENT I'M BREAKING
MOMENTUM.
AS THEY PINPOINT OF MY NUMBERS
BUT I CAN'T WAIT A MONTH OUR
FREE.
HE BUT IT'S SO NICE TO SEE
THOáT QUE.
MáS ARE YOU LIVING APPROVALS
WHICH ADDRESS YES YES YES.
COULD YOU MAKE IT A SHORTER
FIFTH TRANSLATION THANK YOU SO --
THIS IS BEGIN THAT'LL METAL AND
SHE'S BEEN WORKING IN GOVERNMENT
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS SHE
SEPARATES CLOTHING CHECKS
CLOTHING IRONS IN HER CASE
INVESTIGATORS CAME TO THE
FACTORY -- THERE WAS A MEETING
WITH ALL OF THE GARMENT WORKERS
OF THE FACTORY WITH INVESTIGATOR
AND TO LET THEM KNOW THAT THEY
WERE OWED MONEY THEY RECEIVED A
CHECK -- AND THE OWNER OF THE
COMPANY SAID IT I NEED YOU TO
CASH THAT CHECK AND GIVE ME THE
MONEY BACK THAT'S MY MONEY --
AND IF YOU DON'T GIVE ME THE
MONEY BACK YOU LOSE YOUR JOB SO
BE LINED UP LOSING HER JOB AND
THAT IS WHY SHE OPEN UP A CASE
AND AT THE LABOR COMMISSION IN --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SHE SAID AS
A NO SHOW BE ENTERING THE STATE
FUND -- AND HAVE TO ALSO WAY ON
THIS WEIGHTLESS SO PLEASE WE'RE
SEEKING YOUR SUPPORT.
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THAT OF A SIMILAR
ADDRSS WHEN IT COMES?
TO THE NUMBER CENTER WILL PART.
IT'S SO YOU MEMBER SENT FOR THE
COST TO RATTLE.
IT OFTEN OCCURS TO A IN THE
MAKING OF A WHEN A WALKER FOR
MOSTLY.
CAN SAID HOUSE.
IN A PUBLIC HAVE ON THE DRIVE
HOME.
GOT HIM WAS POLLUTION SHORTAGE
MENTAL ILLNESS.
MRS MISSED DEALS.
THE LESS OPEN AS SOON AS COULD
YOU I WILL A CPA OF ORDINAL.
INTERVAL TO START A WHOLE.
IMPAIR FOR ME TO HAVE A WHOLE
THIS HIT AT THE WRONG TIME
[inaudible]
THE ALUMINUM [inaudible]
POLICIES [inaudible]
BUT THAT.
SEVERAL ZERO MINGLE.
THIS HIT ENTER INTO A LOS.
BOTTOM SALARIO LITERACY
INTERCEPTOR CIENTO CINCUENTA
PERSIMMON.
YOUR THING WAS A SEA HORSE YES
TECHNOLOGICAL MATH CONCEPTS PARA.
SO SAY THE CARTOONISTS CALL ME
THAT ORDER AND THE VENDOR THOSE
MILKING SUPPOSING.
TRICHOLOMA ON COMMISSION AL
QAEDA.
FEDERAL SL ATTY.
MINISTER FARRAKHAN TO OKAY THE
CENTER OF OUR HOPE BUT I WANNA
FIGHT A COMMON AFFECTED IT.
MAY PARALYMPIC SHOW FOR PS AND
DESI INTO SEMI Là.
HE SAID WITH A LAUGH.
IT'LL NEVER HAPPEN WITH BASED.
THEN MAKE USHOME CLASS MARCUS
IN THE BATHROOM.
NO CONCEPTION TAX.
MY NOT ONLY CASTLE ON PHONE
LISTA PARA.
EATING ODOROUS ANNUALLY STATUS
BUT BUT IT'S OF ANYONE SECOND
PARTY IT WAS TO HISTORIAS
CONTROL STATUS.
THE CABLES WERE POOR YOU.
CAN MOST BY IT WAS ALLOWED TO
HOST OF THE THIRTY MINUTES THAT
IS THAT THEY SPEND.
THE REST -- SO HIS NAME IS ON
THE BLACK ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
GARMENTS -- WORKERS CENTER HE'S
BEEN WORK IS FAMILY PAY FOR
THEIR EDUCATION PAY FOR RENTS --
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE
OPENED THE CASE AT THE LABOR
COMMISSION BECAUSE THE FACTORY
THAT HE WAS WORKING AT WHAT
PAYING HIM OF SPECIFIC PIECE
RATE. FOR THE FOR US A JOB ONE
DAY AND WHEN HE WAS DOING THE
EXACT SAME JOB IN THE NEXT WEEK
THE PIECE RATE WOULD LOWER --
AND THIS IS VERY COMMON IN THIS
INDUSTRY IN MY CASE THE BRANDS
AND THE BOSS DID NOT PRESENT
THEMSELVES AND SO MY CASE WAS
SENT TO THE STATE FUND I'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR THREE YEARS.
AND WE'RE HERE SHARING OUR
STORIES BECAUSE WE ALSO SEEK
YOUR SUPPORT -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE PAID A JUST WAGE AND
TO GET RID OF THE WAIT LIST IN
THE STATE FUND THANK YOU.
WHEN A STATUS OF THE LOS MINIMUM
DESCENT TO GET THE MAIL IN THIS?
LIKE WHAT WOULD IT UP OF BRING
DANIEL CYSTS ME ME PROVIDES YOU
AND THEN.
YOU LOOK AT A LEVELING MAKING NO
THEY WON'T KNOW HOW.
I WORE LUSA BEST DEALS THAT GALA
LESS INTO THE LOOSEST.
THE MOST FUN WAY PEOPLE CALL IS
THIS IN THE AREA YOU WANT THIS
IS THAT WHAT THAT ARE HANDLING
WILL NOT POVERTY COUPLE TO BE
BILL TRYING YOU.
BUT AS HE SAID THE SKIM IT BUT
I'M BE AMPLE COMMIT BY LAW --
BUT ORDER.
FEDERAL.
LAW ALREADY CONSIDERABLE TO GET
A SENIOR YES THAT ONE DAY THAT.
YOUR A GATE WHEN THE SAID ADAM
THE WAY ILLNESSES SEE THAT IT
WAS GOING TO TRAVEL.
YEAH THE L. ON THAT WE ARE GOING
THROUGH A IBM.
MORE YES THERE.
BUT AT THE LAST POST.
YEAH BUT I WANNA BUT ISSUE.
THE MEMBER YOU'LL LOW CIENTOS
Là CIENTO CINCUENTA.
UNLESS THE MANA THEY SEE IT THEY
A SINGLE THEY LET THAT OF THE NO
I SCHOOLS.
TO LOOK IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT I'M THOUGH. FOR RESTAURANTS
THIS IS THE OF A HOST.
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE YOU IN THE
KNOW SAY THE MEAN NATALIE'S
THOUGH THIS BETA ING IN PALMDALE
IS THE BAND?
DRESSES PERSONAL PM.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AND WE GET THE MELENDEZ I HAVE
BEEN A GREAT LEE AND I ENDED UP --
WITHOUT A JOB I HAVE BEEN
SEARCHING FOR ANOTHER FACTORY
THAT PAID WELL AND HAVE ANY
UNABLE TO SINCE THEN.
I AM NOW WORKING AT A FACTORY
THAT PAYS TWO HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY A WEEK THIS IS IN
A JUST WAGE I ALSO HAVE A CASE
IN THE STATE FUND.
FOR A FACTORY THAT I WORKED AT
THAT PAID A VERY LOW PIECE RATE
AND AGAIN CLOSE THE DOORS FROM
ONE DAY TO THE NEXT -- I'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR THREE YEARS WE'RE
YEARS HERE -- TO SHARE STORIES
AND A ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ELIMINATING THE STATE FUND
WEIGHTLESS.
WHEN THE?
WHEN WHEN THIS THAT IF ANOTHER
ANOTHER ADDRESS NO THE COMMITTEE
THEN?
ME NUMBER IS PROBABLY MEMORY CAN.
FOR A MEMBER OF THE LEAGUE
CENTER THEY GET.
ABOUT HOW THAT IS THE LOCAL
STUDENT.
SINGLE PHASE ANYA THAN LOCAL
STUDENTS.
NOT THAT OF A HORN Là MCKENNA
TAKEOVER SPEECH.
ALBUM CASTLE IN MEMBERS CAN
THINK.
BUT THE METHOD BY HANDLE LOS
CANTOS CINCUENTA THE LETTUCE
BORDERS IN WHEN THEY THINK
CAUGHT US.
HE WELL MY MY AND MUSTAPHA
ACOSTA -- THOUGH.
THE THING WITH A SINUS ESPERANDO.
MEANS ALLOWED TO GO TO A WHILE
[inaudible]
BUT FOR ARE YOU THEN THE ASYLUM
LET.
THADDEUS.
THAN FOR LESS THAT THE US IF WE
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR RUSSELL
IN COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALINA ME
A LOT I AM A MEMBER OF THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER I'VE
WORKED IN GARMENT FOR SIX YEARS.
I A WORK THE COVER STITCH-MACHINE I OPEN THE CASE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN BECAUSE I WAS
PAID VERY LITTLE AT A FACTORY TO
EARN FIFTY DOLLARS FOR FIFTY
FIVE HOURS OF WORK A WEEK -- AND
THE MANAGER WAS ALSO HARASSING
ME.
I'VE BEEN WAITING THREE YEARS --
FOR MY STOLEN WAGES IN THE STATE
FUND.
PLEASE HELP US ELIMINATE THE
WAIT LIST FOR THE STATE FUND
THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THAT THIS HAD TO US?
NOBODY'S GOT A MENTOR HE'S.
THIRTY MEANDER THE CINQUE INTO
THAT BECAUSE TO THE THE LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
SINGLE THE LINK THAT I KNEW THAT
THAT I'VE HAD INCLUDES.
TO ROOM WITH THE TV AND THE WAY
THAT.
JOEY ME MORE TO HAVE WARS IN ME
THAT OUR WHOLE.
COMO FIVE ONE FOURTH BE IS SAN
FOR THIRTEEN THOUSAND THAT P. IS
THAT.
GROWING IS HAND MAD YOU IS GOING
BAD.
IN JUNE OF A IT'S TIME I HOST.
ME A VICTIM WHICH TOOK PLACE ON
NINE MEAN.
NO MAN CAN TELL I'M PAN AND THEN
BEING THAT.
THE WE QUE YOU DONATE LYCIA I
BELIEVE HOME YOU THAT BUT THAT'S
OVER THE TV.
IT IS EITHER FORTY FIVE BORDER
CAN ATTEND TO THEM.
GOING FOR THIS THAT THAT WOULD
GET YOU THINK ALL THE DESIGN YOU
THAT THEY NEED IN THE MIDDLE
YOUR OWN NEWMAN THEM BY HAND.
INDUSTRY AS A TRIMMER.
I LIVED THROUGH MANY OF USES
SUCH AS PAYMENT BY PIECE RATE
AND CONSTANT WAGE THEFT.
AT ONE OF THOSE JOBS IT REALLY
AFFECTED ME PERSONALLY I DID NOT
MAKE ENOUGH TO PAY FOR RENT AND
I HAD TO GO TO A CHURCH TO ASK
FOR FOOD TO SURVIVE -- I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
BECAUSE I HAVE A CASE THAT'S
BEEN WAITING M. IT WITHIN THE
STATE FUND FOR THREE YEARS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
YES YES.
WHEN I STARTED THIS I NOTICE
FINANCE ANOTHER ORDER WITH
AWESOME?
LIVING WAS PLAN WE PROGRAM.
WE KNOW MINUTES KOREAN OFFICE.
REMEMBER THE ASSEMBLY ACROSS
FLORIDA.
THE OUR HOLDING TENURE AS A
MEDICAL STUDENT.
MOST WELCOME ONE WAY FIVE CLOSE
ONE COMES UP ON EITHER.
BUT ACCORDING IS THE BALANCE.
INSPIRED ON THE QUOTE PERCENT
PROBLEMS OUT THERE SINCE I WOULD
LOVE PIZZA.
IN A YELLOW CAM AND MILES OKAY
SO LOC INFLUENCE IN THE SINK
WHEN.
THEY LEARN IS HOW SOMEONE WILL
BE ROAMING WHAT MAKES THIS.
IRIS IS HEREBY AUTHORIZED FOR ME
FAST.
A SECOND IS THIS WAY.
TO HELLO IS THIS LIKE THE FEES
HIM.
AND MOST THE ONE FOR ME YES.
AS MAY SENCILLOS YES
[inaudible]
S..
MICHAEL LET ME THE CONSENT OF
THE COST FOOD.
IT OPENS FROM NINE YEARS FREE
WHICH MONTH THAT TO ME AS SOON
AS WELL THE FILE AND LOW AND FOR
OUR HOME IN MY MIND AND YEAH
THIS IS A DIFFERENT. ONE LOS.
MY LITTLE WORLD POST.
THEN MY LARA MONNING STAFF.
YOUR THE LOWER CASE THEY SCIENCE
I MEAN MY BODY QUE.
THE EC A SETTLEMENT WITH FEDERAL
SEE WITH OUR THEME PARK RIDE ME.
YEAH BUT I MEAN.
IT WAS THE V. EIGHT AND I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN OUR RATHER.
YEAH BUT AMY CANCEL.
AND ALLOWS ME TO USE A GRAMMY.
RENDON WEEK ASSIGNMENT LOW'S
RELATED YES HE AT THE END PHONES
IS ALMOST AVAILABLE ONE OF BY
WILL.
SENATE SUTHERLAND INFORMACIóN
FOUND.
IN A WOMAN ASIDE USING.
AT THAT ME MADDEST AT LEAST THAT
IS BETTER.
WHAT IS IN THE HOUSE HE AND?
WE TOOK IT AS HIS.
SAID GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ALSO
MY NAME IS HOLLY AND ABOUT THE
SENATE I'M A MEMBER OF THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER AND I'VE
WORKED IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
SHE SAID BY THE PAY IS SO LOW
THAT WE CAN'T COVER A BASIC MISS.
WE SUFFERS GARMENT WORKERS --
ALL FORTY FIVE THOUSAND OF US IN
AND LOS ANGELES.
MY POSITION WAS -- TO FINISH THE
GARMENT -- AND WHEN I'D I'M NOT
PAID WELL I CAN'T COVER MY RENT --
THERE'S ALSO -- BAD WORKING
CONDITIONS RATS ROACHES -- AND A
LOT OF HUMILIATION AND
MISTREATMENT -- THE EVEN THROW
THINGS AT AS I'VE SID I WORK
SIX YEARS IN THE SAME FACTORY
AND ONE DAY IT CLOSED AND I WAS
LEFT WITHOUT WORK WITHOUT PAY
WITHOUT MY TOOLS I WENT TO THE
LABOR COMMISSION IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND I WON IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUT I'VE
BEEN WAITING SINCE THEN ON THEM
THE WAIT LIST FOR THE STATE FINE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THE S.?
WHEN A SPECIALIST BUT ALONE THE
S. AND OTHER [inaudible]
THE RESTROOM.
YEP -- LET'S GET THEM PRESIDENT.
WE NUMBER IS SENT UP WALK.
ME IN RENTAL CENTER THE GOSPEL
DATUMS.
MY THAT IS ALSO A HOST.
THANK ADDRESS SEVEN YEARS.
BUT OUR HONDA ENOUGH FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE BEHIND THEM I
CAN EITHER WILL NOW WILL CRAP
CLOSELY AND DON'T ROLL.
FIVE BANDAI LONEY'S WILLOWS AS
BEST THE THOSE.
THOUGH THAT BLESSED THAT REAL
FAST.
YOU'LL GET AVAILABLE YOU KNOW
THAT IT WILL BE AT NO FIVE BY
MAD HE LIES BUT THE SEAL ON IT
OR WHAT IS A LIE DIEM.
LAST MY LAST CONDICIONES THE
LAST PUBLIC PRESS.
YES IT KICKS IS THEREFORE LIST
THAT BAD.
HERE.
RIGHT THEY NEED OKAY WITH THAT
LOW YOUR YOUR CARE OKAY INFORMED
US THAT THAT.
THAT OUR HE BE IN FRIDAY IS AND
IF THE SHOW THEY LAND TO STAY AT
THE LEVELS BELOW.
TO IS THERE A KEEP IT UP WE ALL
PRESENT MY NAME IS ON THAT BLOCK
I AM A MEMBER OF THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER HAVE BEEN WORKING
IN IN GARMENT FOR THIRTEEN YEARS.
I OPERATE -- THE OVER LOCK AND
SINGLE NEEDLE MACHINES -- I SEEK
THE GOVERNMENT SUPPORT TO STOP
THE EXPLOITATION AND IS THE WAGE
THEFT IN GARMENT INDUSTRY I KNOW
THAT THE STATE FUND EXIST I'VE
NEVER HAD TO USE T -- BUT I DO
WANT THE STATE FUNDS TO WORK
WELL FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
GOVERNMENT WORKERS AND THE
INDUSTRY.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
MY FELLOW GARMENT WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN WAITING A
VERY LONG TIME TO SEE JUSTICE
THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS?
YEAH ME NUMBER A IS NORMAL.
THE THREE MEMBER OF THE CENTRAL
FROM HOWARD IS A LOT OF STUDENTS.
HE'D BEEN GOING THROUGH THE
DESIGN YOU START A HUNDRED LOCAL
STUDENT.
IS FORTY THREE ME OF ORDER.
THREE AMY THIS CITY I REMEMBER
ME BUT FROM PARKING.
WHICH ALSO KNOWS THAT THE
ARRIVAL OF A WHOLE THIS HIT THE
FACE [inaudible]
HE A MY TOP ASSEMBLY IN.
AARON.
DELUDE ELECTROLUX CAN RESPOND ON
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THAT
IS GOING ON IS SOMETHING CALLED
A LOT A LOT.
ONE WE GET TO EVEN PUT A LOT
ABOUT MR CITY.
YOU GET ORGANISED BARGAIN IT'S A
LOT TO ME ANYMORE.
DE LA WELCOME WE TURN OUR LEGAL
COUNSEL IN IT.
ENABLES ME GOT THOUGHT.
YOUR AVAILABLE MENDEECEES FACE.
IT ISN'T ON THE FIFTH FOR YES
BUT ON THE FORMS OF FUND.
YOU'LL GET WARMER SEE WAS THAT
IN THOSE PUEDEN AYUDAR.
RAC REAL THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
FORGET THOUGHT ABOUT MORE
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT ON
MY WHEEL I AM A MEMBER OF THE
GARMENT WORKER CENTER I WORKED
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS AS A TREMOR.
I DECIDED TO FILE A WAGE CLAIM
BECAUSE OF THE LONG HOURS I WORK
FROM SEVEN AM TO SIX PM.
AND BECAUSE OF THE VIEWS AND
BECAUSE OF THE PIECE RATE WHICH
ACTUALLY ONLY COMES OUT TO ABOUT
THREE TO FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
I BECAME VERY STRESSED OUT BY
THE SITUATION I WANT TO BE PAID
THE MINIMUM WAGE BECAUSE MY
WAGES DON'T COVER MY RENTER
BILLS.
I WENT TO THE LABOR COMMISSION
TO OPEN A CASE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND ONE MY CASE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SINCE THEN
I'VE BEEN WAITING ON PAYMENT
FROM THE STATE FUND.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT SO WE
CAN RECEIVE PAYMENT BECAUSE THE
WAIT LIST IS TOO LONG THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MARCIN NEWS HILL AND I AM THE
PROUD DIRECTOR OF THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER AND GET TO
ORGANIZE AND WORK WITH THIS
WONDERFUL GROUP OF WORKERS --
I'M HERE ON OUR BEHALF AND ON
BEHALF OF BUT PSAMTIK AT UCLA
LABOR CENTER AND TWENTY SEVEN
SUPPORTING ORGANIZATIONS AND
UNIONS -- AND WE'RE SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE.
EIGHTY OUR CENTER IS LOCATED IN
THE HEART OF THE LOS ANGELES
GARMENT DISTRICT.
AND OUR CENTER WE ORGANIZE -- TO
FIGHT TO IMPROVE.
WORKING CONDITIONS AND WAGES AND
IS PART OF THAT EFFORT WE
OPERATE A LEGAL CLINIC -- AND
REPRESENT WORKERS IN THEIR WAGE
CLAIMS WITH THE STATE LABOR
COMMISSION.
YOU'VE JUST HEARD FROM OUR
MEMBERS GARMENT WORKERS TO
TRAVEL FROM LOS ANGELES
OVERNIGHT. TO TELL YOU THEIR
STORIES OF LABOR EXPLOITATION.
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM OUR
MEMBERS AND WHAT WE'VE EARNED
THROUGH OUR CLINIC IS HOW
DIFFICULT AND RISKY IT CAN BE TO
FOLLOW WAGE CLAIM?
WORKERS NAVIGATE A COMPLICATED
LEGAL SYSTEM.
AND IN DOING SO THEY REST
TERMINATION THEY RISK
IMMIGRATION RELATED THREATS AND
THEY RISK BLACKLISTING.
THEY THEN WAIT THEY THEN CAN
WAIT FOR UP TO TWO YEARS FOR
THEIR CLAIM TO BE RESOLVED.
AND WHEN THEY WIN THEIR WA AND
THEY OFTEN FACE -- THE FACT THAT
THE EMPLOYERS MANUFACTURERS DO
NOT PAY UP.
WORKERS THAT ARE TRYING TO THE
GARMENT FIND IT WHERE THEY SAY
AND A YEARS LONG WAITING LIST --
IN MEANWHILE THERE'S STRUGGLING
AS YOU HEARD TO COVER RENT AND
BASICALLY BEING EXPENSES.
THE STATE CREATED THE GARMENT
FUNDS AND IN DOING SO AGREED TO
ACT AS THE PAIR OF LAST RESORT.
TO GUARANTEE PAYMENT TO THIS
VULNERABLE WORK FORCE.
THE EXISTING WEIGHTLESS
UNDERMINES THAT PURPOSE.
ANY TO ROADS WORKERS TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT.
AND DISSUADES WORKERS FROM
SEEKING TO RECOVER THEIR UNPAID
WAGES.
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
RECENT TRANSFER INTO THE GARMENT
PLAN FUNDS THAT WILL PAY
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO WORKERS THIS IS REALLY
EXCITING PROGRESS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK HIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORT HOWEVER TO
ELIMINATE.
THE NTIRE WEIGHT LISTA WORKERS
MAY FINALLY RECEIVE JUSTICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JESSICA
BARTH LOWER THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY WE'VE
PROVIDED SOME PRO BONO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE GOVERNMENT
WORKER CENTER -- AS PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY LAWYER AND WESTERN
CENTER -- JUST WANTED TO RELAY
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WORK GROUPS
HAD A MEETING LAST WEEKEND TO
DISCUSS THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE --
AND SUPPORT AT EITHER WAY A
TRAILER BILL OR BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT COULD CONTINUE --
TO BE TRANSFERRED INTO THE
ACCOUNT -- THEY WOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF EITHER THAT AS
LONG AS A SOMETHING YOU BROUGHT
UP AS LONG AS IT WOULDN'T HARM
OTHER WORKERS.
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A BEAUTIFUL --
YOU KNOW KIND OF SOLIDARITY
BETWEEN WORKERS.
AT SO DISAPPOINTED OUT AND AND
IT WESTERN CENTER AS YOU HEARD
THE THE WORKERS ARE IN LINES AT
FOOD PANTRIES -- THEY'RE THEY'RE
STRUGGLING WITH POVERTY AND AND
OUR OUR CLIENTS SO WE ARE PROUD
TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
REQUEST THANK YOU.
I HAVE A MY NAME IS PREVENTIVA
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR WORKERS RIGHTS WERE
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- AB
NONPROFIT AND WE REPRESENT LOW
WAGE WORKERS AT WE'RE HERE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE GARMENT
WORKERS -- AND FOR OPENING UP
THE FUNDS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
PAID WE BELIEVE AND AGAIN.
HONEST PAY FOR HONEST WORK AND
AND OBVIOUSLY THE THEY'VE ALL
WITH THEIR STORIES THEY'VE ALL
SHARED EXACTLY THAT THAT THEY
ARE ENTITLED TO THE PAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REYES HERE YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT WITH A LINER TELLS
WITH THE WESTERN CENTERS
COMMENTS THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE WAS IMMEDIATE LABOR SO I
STAYED IN SUPPORT SOLIDARITY
WITH THESE WITH THESE FOLKS.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
ENTERTAINING THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TASK FORCE THAT BRINGS
THE VERY SAGES TOGETHER FOR THE
PURPOSE ONE OF AN ECONOMY.
AND THE COMMENTS ARE BEING ADE
BY THESE PEOPLE THE ABUSE BY
SOME OF THESE EMPLOYERS IS AN
EXAMPLE WE FIGHT FOR EVERY TIME
WE MEET -- I WOULD IMPLORE THAT
THAT WHATEVER YOU COULD POSS DUE
TO ASSIST OUR EFFORTS IN SUPPORT
OF WHAT THE RAPTURE TODAY WOULD
BE.
RE SORRY APPRECIATE US NOT ONLY
A MIGHT BE UP OF THE HAVE THE
MEMBERS THE LABORS UNION
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
ALSO FURTHER AYE I THINK I'D
NEED TO COMBAT THE SOMEHOW WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT SOMEHOW
PLEASE EFFORTS AND SORRY NOT AN
ANSWER THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN KNOWN THAT
LABOR COMMISSION NEEDS TO ACT ON
THESE ISSUES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
AND NOT STAND IN LINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WELL.
IT'S GOT TO BE.
IT SHOULD BE SHOCKING. TO
EVERYBODY ANYWHERE EVERYWHERE
THAT IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY OF SO
MUCH WEALTH.
WE COULD HAVE PEOPLE LINED UP
LIKE THIS ONE AFTER ANOTHER
AFTER ANOTHER. TO TALK ABOUT A
CLAIM THAT WAS FILED. THREE FOUR
FIVE YEARS AGO. ONE I SAY THAT
YOU KNOW IN [inaudible]
IN THE THEY WON THEIR CASE.
BUT THEY DIDN'T WIN.
BECAUSE THEY STILL HAVEN'T BEEN
PAID -- AND IT TO BE TREATED
THAT WAY AND THEN WHEN YOU GO TO
OUR GOVERNMENT AND FILE A CLAIM
WITH THE EXPECTATION.
THAT.
IF YOU WIN AGAIN IF YOU WIN YOUR
CASE YOU'RE GOING TO GET PAID.
SO THEY GO THROUGH THAT THEIR
TRUST IN THE GOVERNMENT OUGHT TO
DO THAT AND STILL.
THEY DON'T GET PAID -- AND I
THINK FOR THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
WITHIN OUR BUDGET WE'VE GOT TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
SO.
WHATEVER THAT IS WHATEVER THAT
AMOUNT IS WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MOVE THAT FORWARD BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE.
AS A STATE GOVERNMENT ALLOW THIS
TO JUST KEEP HAPPENING THEY
EXPECT.
IF THEY DO WHAT THEY'RE TOLD TO
DO A FILING THE CLAIM THEY
EXPECT TO BE PAID.
AND THEN I GETTING PAID.
SO WHATEVER IT TAKES -- THIS
THIS LEVEL OF WAGE THAT IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
AND EVERYBODY SHOULD BE OUTRAGED
BY IT AND I CERTAINLY WILL DO
WHATEVER I CAN. TO BE HELPFUL
YOU LET'S GET ON THE LIST THAT I
SAYS THAT THOSE WAS THAT THIS
WAS TO BY LAW.
THE INCIDENT BROUGHT US TO
SIMPLY OF THE LOTUS.
REPORTER BUT NEEDED TO MINE I
SAID IT'LL BE AHEAD OF ANY THE
SPECTRA.
BUT QUE IS AVAILABLE SO SO IT
WHEN THE SPELL NONE I SEE.
ONE KID IN THE BAND BADLY GUESTS
ON HE GIVES THERE'S NO PROCESS
BY THE BY GOD.
WHOSE FOOD LIKE LEVELS THAT WAS
GAS -- SO YOU'LL UPPER SO NOW
YOU'RE SICK YOU'RE GONNA GO GET
HIM BUT WHAT THE NAME ALMOST AT
THE END OF A BOIL AGAIN MYSTICAL
ME DAY.
BINA THAT THAT'LL MUST PERCEIVE
Là IS SIMPLY A LOS WONDER THE
SOCIETIES BUT A BY LIST.
MIDDLE COLUSA SEVEN IS THIS
CYNICAL SPENT THE LUCHA SO
NOTHING PERSONAL MUCHO WHO'S
THIS IS TO BE AND I THINK IT IS
BUT I DON'T BONTA SORT US BUT
WITH THIS THE ONE YOU.
BUILDING A LOOK OR SO WOULD OKAY.
I KEEP TENANTS FROM THE SCAN THE
SUBWAY SO COULD I SYSTEM.
OR WE CAN TAKE YES SIR.
RIGHT ON TO YOUR NEXT ITEM IF I
MAY HAVE FIFTEEN SECONDS -- AND
IF THE RISK OF SPEAKING OUT OF
TURN.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
ACCELERATE THE RESERVE
RESOLUTION OF THESE CLAIMS WERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
WEALTHIEST AND YOU'RE NOT OUT OF
PLACE.
OKAY -- YOU'RE NOT A PLACE WITH
ME I DON'T KNOW WHAT ANYBODY
ELSE THINKS ABOUT YOU BUT YOU'RE
NOT OUT OF PLACE WITH ME AND
YOUR YOUR SUGGESTIONS -- THANK
YOU MA'AM.
OKAY -- WE CAN VOTE TODAY -- BUT
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA.
DO WHATEVER WE CAN -- TO KEEP
THIS ISSUE ALIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM.
YOU KNOW MR MAY HAS BEEN WAITING
FOR THAT ITEM.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THAT'S IS THAT THOSE.
POSTED IS THERE WITH YOU
[inaudible]
AND WELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR HIGH SURPRISE SAY
WHOLESOME HE AGAIN WILL WE SEE
COVERAGE TO COUNSEL LABORS THANK
YOU.
THE LABORS FOR MANY MANY YEARS
HAVE BEEN -- OF ADDED STRONG
PRESSES WITHIN REMEDIATION
INDUSTRY ARE IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY -- IN
CALIFORNIA THE ONE FOR EACH
WE'VE BEEN FINDING OURSELVES
FACED WITH THESE TERRIFIC AN
UNFORTUNATE FIRES UP A BIT ON
THE STATE.
AS A RESULT OF THOSE FIRES THE
TRAINING AND THE RE
CERTIFICATIONS INDIVIDUALS IN
THE LEAD ABATEMENT INDUSTRY HAS
DRASTICALLY INCREASED.
ALSO WITH THAT ALSO COMES WITH
THE NOTION THAT.
THAT -- WE ARE.
DESPERATELY SEEKING THAT THE CAL
OSHA -- THE ACCELERATES.
AN UPDATE THE EXPOSURE LEVELS
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED FOR
MANY MANY YEARS.
I BELIEVE THAT THE INITIAL
INTENT WAS TO START BACK IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND THE REGULATION
HAS NOT BEEN ADOPTED HAS NOT
BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
ALL I KNOW OF HAVE CONVERSATIONS
QUITE ABILITY PART AND US
RELATIONS ON IS A VERY LEVELS.
I UNDERSTAND THEY ARE WORKING ON
IT -- BUT AGAIN THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
AND NOTHING HAS HAPPENED.
MEANWHILE THE THE EXPOSURE
LEVELS CONTINUE TO RISE IN MANY
CASES THESE FOLKS END UP WITH NO
EMPLOYMENT DUE TO THE FACT.
THAT THEY GET TO THE TO THE
LEVELS THAT THEY NO LONGER
MEDICALLY COULD CONTINUE WORKING.
THE A TICKET COUPLE SECONDS HERE
COLLEGES AND WORKING VERY
CLOSELY IN REVISING THE PL.
BUT AS JONES THE OR KNOWN AS A
GENERAL INDUSTRY LED STANDARD
AND CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY LED
STANDARD FOR THE PROTECTION OF
WORKERS WERE EXPOSED TO LEAD ON
THE JOB.
I AM I DEBT.
IN ADDITION TO THE FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ABOUT A
MASSIVE EFFORT TO BE ABLE TO
REMOVE ALL LEAD IN PAINT.
IN AS BEST AS AN INSTALLATION
ETCETERA ETCETERA AND MANY OF
OUR OLDER BUILDINGS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHICH ALSO OF COURSE
INCREASES NUMBER WORKERS EXPOSED.
TO THESE LEVELS.
THE CRYSTAL REQUIRES THAT EVERY
EMPLOYER SHALL ENSURE THAT NO
EMPLOYEES EXPOSED TO LEAD A
CONCENTRATIONS GREATER THAN
FIFTY MICROGRAMS PER CUBIC METER
OF AIR AVERAGED OVER AN EIGHT
HOUR PERIOD.
I MIGHT ADD THAT IN MOST CASES
THESE ARE MORE THAN EIGHT HOURS
SHIPS.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE
TO DO IT IN MANY CASES WERE
EXPOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
THE STAIRS BASED ON MEDICAL AND
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION IS MORE
THAN THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD OVER
THIS TIME MUCH HAS BEEN LEARNED
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF LEAD AMONG
ADULTS AT LOWER EXPOSURE LEVELS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CURRENT SIZE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
PERSPECTIVES IN A NATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM AND THE US
EPA STRONGLY INDICATES THE WORK
OF LEVELS.
THAT LOCAL BLOOD LEAD LEVELS
SHOULD NOT EXCEED TWO FIVE TO
TEN MICROGRAMS PER CUBIC METER
OVER A WORKING LIFETIME NEVER
MIND EIGHT HOUR DAY.
YET EXISTING STANDARDS Là
WORKERS TO HAVE BLOOD.
LEAD LEVELS UP TO FIFTY TO SIXTY
MICROGRAMS.
PER CUBIC METER BEFORE THEY HAVE
TO BE REMOVED FROM SIGNIFICANT
LEAD EXPOSURE.
THE P. L. X. IS IT PROPOSED TO
BE UPDATED TO REFLECT CURRENT
MEDICAL SCIENCE AND ESTABLISH A
MORE PROTECTIVE STANDARD FOR LET
CONSTRUCTION PROFESSIONALS.
BUT IT HAS BEEN EIGHT YEARS
SINCE THE ROOM MAKING WAS OPEN
AND THE REVISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE.
DISTILLATES HARMING WORKERS
INCLUDING MY OWN MEMBERS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INCREASED
EXPOSURE MY MEMBERS ARE.
FACING A PERFORMING ALL THE
WILDLIFE.
WELL FAR CLEANUP WORK PROCESS
STATE THERE'S NO REASON THEY
SHOULD BE OPERATING ON THE
STANDARDS BASED ON A THIRTY FIVE
REAL SCIENCE.
I JUST I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT SOMEHOW WE COULD POSSIBLY
DO THIS COMMITTEE EXPEDITE --
CAL OSHA TO ACT ON THIS
IMMEDIATELY WHILE THEY'RE SAYING
THAT TWENTY TWENTY OR MID TWENTY
TWENTY WOULD BE IT WHEN THEY
COME UP WITH THAT.
I THINK THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN
BE VERY HELPFUL IN EXPEDITING
THIS FOR THE SAKE OF ALL THESE
WORKERS.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
APPROVAL.
YOU'RE VERY MINUTE -- BUT COMMON
ARE I WOULD ONLY ADD IN THE
DEPARTMENT CONCUR THAT THAT WE
NEED TO MOVE ON THIS AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN I CAN'T.
SPEAK.
TO OF THE TIME SPAN THAT THAT.
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AND TOOK A SQUARED WE ARE TODAY --
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
INCORPORATED ALL DRAFT FEEDBACK?
OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS MOVED TO
THE REGULATORY PACKAGE TO OTHER
LABOR IN THE WORKFORCE AGENCY
FOR APPROVAL -- IT WILL THEN GO
BACK TO A FORMAL SUBMISSION TO
FINANCE AND THEN -- TO OF THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS DONE WHAT IT
CAN THE IN THIS PROCESS THERE IS
AN APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
REGULATION FOR REGULATION'S BUT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT CANNOT
LEGALLY CIRCUMVENT.
SOUL -- WE ARE WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT IT HAS TAKEN US THIS LONG
TO GT HERE -- BUT WE ARE
WORKING EXPEDITIOUSLY.
IN THE PROCESS WHICH WOULD WHICH
WE LIST IT HERE AT THIS TIME SO
WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG.
WHAT I MEAN?
SERIOUSLY THIS IS THIS JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND AND I I I
RESPECT WOULD YOU SAY THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVE IN ALL THIS UT
THAT'S NOT WORKING.
AND AND A WHAT IS IT GOING TO
TAKE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE I KNOW
THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
WOULD THEY WILL HAVE A BACKLOG
OR SOMETHING IS GOING ON THAT'S
TAKING LONGER FAST FOR MORE
STAFF DOES WERE RESOURCES WE'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR MONTHS NOW.
TAKING UP REQUEST. FOR MORE
STAFFING MORE RESOURCES WHAT IS
IT GONNA TAKE.
AND HERE I HONESTLY I CANNOT
DEFEND THE TIME THAT THEY TOOK
FROM. 200-011-22000 AND SIXTEEN
WE COULD TO MOVE TO TO BEGIN TO
TAKE ACTION ON THESE REGULATIONS
I KNOW ALL THAT.
EXHAUSTIVE MEETINGS WERE HER OR
HELD BUT FRANKLY I JUST I'M I'M
BEING AS HONEST IN THIS
TRANSPARENT AND CANDID AS I CAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED I
DON'T KNOW WHAT CAUSED.
THE DELAY ALL I CAN SPEAK TO
GOING FORWARD IS WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW AND PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ASSURANCE THAT WE
ARE WORKING AS EXPEDITIOUSLY.
AS WE CAN.
YES AND JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT --
THIS REGULATION I HAS AN
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
TRIGGERS THE THE THE
STANDARDIZED REGULATION IMPACT
ANALYSIS THE SHARIA AND SO THAT
CERTAIN THE REQUIRES A YOU KNOW
DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND AND SO -- YOU KNOW WE'VE
RECEIVED A DROP OF THE YEAR OF
THE I. R. SRI -- WE'VE EEN
WORKING WITH THEM SINCE WE'VE
MOVED OUT MANY OF THE CONCERNS
AND I THINK AT THIS POINT.
ADD THE REGULATION SHOULD BE
READY BY MID -- TWENTY TWENTY AS
AND WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE
UPDATED DROPS WITH ALL OF OUR
WOULD BE UPDATED TRAPS BUT WE'RE
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
RECEIVING A AND AND MOVING THIS
REGULATION ALONG AND AND YES.
SO WHY WOULD DO IT WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE ANOTHER YEAR PLUS IF THE IT
IF I MAY SPEAK TO THAT QUESTION --
THE THE APPROVAL PROCESS UNDER
THE ADMINISTRATIVE -- OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW MAY TAKE UP
TO A YEAR THIS IS A MAJOR
REGULATION.
IT IS POSSIBLE WHEN I CAN'T
PROMISE ANYTHING BECAUSE WHEN I
AM CONTROL THAT PROCESS BUT IF
THE DEPARTMENT HAS DONE ITS WORK
WELL IF THOSE MEETINGS.
STAKEHOLDERS MEETINGS THAT TOOK
PLACE RECEIVED A THAT INPUT FROM
THE COMMUNITY IF THIS PACKAGE IS
REFLECTIVE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
THE PACKAGE COULD MOVE MUCH MORE
QUICKLY THAN THAT.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT I CAN'T
PROVIDING ASSURANCE OF THAT THE
ONE THING I CAN SAY IS THAT THIS
PACKAGE GOALS BEYOND JUST THE
PALE LIMIT. TO ALSO THE ACTION
LEVEL WHICH IS ANOTHER LAYER OF
PROTECTION SO IT REVISES.
OF THE PILL LIMITS AS THE
GENTLEMAN HAS COMENTED ON BUT
IT GOES BEYOND -- THOSE SPELL
LIMITS IT IS A STRONGER
PROTECTION THAN CHEST REVISING
THE PALE LIMITS A LOT.
AND SO I'M NOT A SCIENTIST I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THEM ANYMORE THAN
I ALREADY HAVE -- BUT WE'RE
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THE PROCESS
WILL NOT TAKE A YEAR BUT TO MR
HIM IN THIS IS POINT.
IT IS NOT UNUSUAL IF IF WE ARE
REQUIRED.
COULD GOAL THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. TWO IN ACTED
THIS REGULATION.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON THAT THE
PROCESS TAKES A YEAR.
THE SERVER MAY.
YOU KNOW THE FACT THE MATTER IS
IF THERE IS A HECK UP IN THE
PROCESS.
IF IN FACT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
FOUND THAT THERE'S THEY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH CERTAIN STEPS TO
ACQUIRE AND GET THE REGULATION
IN PLACE IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THAT AT SOME POINT.
SOMEBODY WOULD COME UP IN FLAG
THAT UP AND SAID YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THIS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT WE'RE HAVING TO DO
WITH THIS OR THE OTHER.
AND THERE HASN'T BEEN ANYTHING
ON THAT IS THE ONLY REASON I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU.
BECAUSE IF IT'S IF IT'S A MATTER
OF THE TYPICAL GOVERNMENT SLOW
DOWN AS WITH HER FOR THE PRIOR
PRESENTATION.
THEN.
YOU KNOW AT LEAST SOMEBODY GO
AND START.
FLAGGING IT TO YOU ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
AND THESE PEOPLE IN MANY CASES.
RELEASE MY EMPLOYERS WE MONITOR
THEM WE MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
EMPLOYERS ARE ARE MONITORING THE
EXPOSURE LEVELS.
WHAT ABOUT ALL THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN NO REPRESENTATION THAT HAD
DO NOT HAVE AN OVERSIGHT FROM A
THIRD PARTY FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
ABSOLUTE?
BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY DIRTY
TYPE ACTIVITY IT'S A LOWEST PAID
IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND IN THE CONSTRUCTION THIS
RESULT WAS PAID.
YET THE MOST HAZARDOUS.
SO I WOULD BE OF THE DEPARTMENT
THAT WHAT THEY COULD MAKES
COMMITTEES IS GONNA TAKE ONE
MORE YEAR TO THE MINISTRY OF LAW.
I WOULD HOPE THAT BY THE GET
TIME TO GET TO THAT POINT TO
THIRTY THERE'S WITH IT IT TAKES
IN A YEAR AND NOT ANOTHER FIVE
YEARS.
MR HELLO ANY COMMENTS.
WELL.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE MOST
DISAPPOINTING PART OF THE FIRST
IS THE NUMBER OF YEARS IT'S
TAKEN.
BUT THERE'S NO PLAN.
REALLY TO EXPEDITE THIS.
IF I MAY THERE'S NEVER THERE AND
LISTEN UNDERSTAND BUT AND NO I I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE
MISUNDERSTANDING NECESSARILY I
JUST WONDER [inaudible]
GENTLY CORRECT WHAT AGES.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS NO CAPACITY.
TO ACCELERATE THIS PROCESS FROM
THIS POINT BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T OWN THE
PROCESS -- OF THIS HAS TO GO
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IT HAS TO GO TO THE
STANDARDS BOARD WHICH IS A
SEPARATE ENTITY THAT HAS
JURISDICTION OVER THIS MATTER IT
HAS TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE POWER. TO
SET THAT PROCESS ASIDE.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU SET
THE PROCESS ASIDE I'M SUGGESTING
THAT YOU HAD THE STAFFING YOU
COULD MOVE THE PROCESS FORWARD I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THAT SO IF
IS STAFF IN AN ISSUE I FINISHED
LAUGHING WAS AN ISSUE.
I CAN'T SENATE STAFFING IS AN
ISSUE TODAY.
BECAUSE WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
BUT IT IS POSSIBLE THAT.
THE SLOWDOWN OR OF THE INACTION
WAS IMPACTED BY MANY THINGS I
DON'T HAVE PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE OF
THAT -- BUT OBVIOUSLY WE DID NOT
MOVE ON THIS REGULATION AS
QUICKLY AS WE COULD I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE ANY EXCUSES AT ALL IT'S
CLEAR THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT
DISPUTE IN ANY WAY.
THAT IT SHOULD HAVE MOVED FASTER.
VISUAL SENATOR RESO AND DANIEL
BRAND WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCEI JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
YOU KNOW AS WE IDENTIFIED THERE
ISN'T THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW PROCESS --
WHICH WE ARE IN NOW SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT STAFFING IS AN
ISSUE IT D. I. R. IT'S GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS GETTING IT
PASSED FINANCE REVIEW -- WE ARE
LOOKING INTO THE IMPACTS AND AT
A FIFTY DOLLAR A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR MY APOLOGIES.
AND MINIMUM IMPACT TO BE A MAJOR
REGULATION THERE IS A LOT GOING
ON HERE -- AND SO WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT I DON'T THINK
STAFFING IS AN ISSUE AT THIS
TIME AS WE ARE JUST NOW.
ENTERING INTO THIS HE SAID WE
RECEIVE THIS FREE AND ARE
ENTERING IN THE LA L. PROCESS
THEM WITH THAT GOES INTO A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
AND JUST THE REQUIRED TIME
FRAMES FOR THOSE PROCESSES AND
THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE SECOND IN TERMS OF
TWO GROUPS THE WORKERS HERE NOT
A HAPPY MOMENT FOR ME NO I KNOW
IT'S NOT FOR YOU AND IT'S NOT
IT'S WORSE. FOR THEM.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE YOUR HEALTH.
MANY OF THOSE WORKERS DON'T HAVE
TO HELP.
YOU HAVE YOUR PAYCHECK OF THOSE
WORKERS DON'T HAVE THEIR
PAYCHECK I YOU KNOW WE HAVE GOT.
TO YOU HAVE GOT OR WHOEVER ELSE
ON YOUR TEAM WE HAVE GOT TO PAY
MORE ATTENTION TO THESE ISSUES
EITHER GETTING THEIR RESOURCES
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO DO CARRY OUT YOUR WORK.
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
I'M JUST SAYING WE'VE GOT TO
GIVE.
WE GOT TO GIVE MORE ATTENTION TO
THIS SO WE WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DIVISION AND WORKING WITH
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED TO HELP
INSURE.
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS DOES
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
OKAY.
THANKS THANK YOU. TO EVERYONE --
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT I'M SORRY
YES PUBLIC COMMENT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MORRISON
ANSWER DIRECTOR OF THE GARMENT
WORKER CENTER ON ISSUE.
EIGHTY ONE WE'RE HERE TO SPEAK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF MOVING
FORWARD AND DOING WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO MOVE FOR THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO PROTECT WORKER
HEALTH.
WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT WORKER
HEALTH IS PARAMOUNT AND ALL OF
OUR OBLIGATION TO CARE ABOUT AND
WE WERE HERE TO BE IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE LABORS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
VOTERS.
I DON'T THIK EVERYBODY THANK
YOU TO THIS [inaudible]
THE FOR THE YEAH